Or Drum on his show
and we'll live.
This is what I love about
bill burr. You're not like
a regular comedian. You're,
I mean, you're a great comic, but
you do shit. You do a lot of shit.
You don't just sit around and get
lazy and fuck off and you make cakes.
You,
you made pie homemade pie from scratch.
Bill burr brought in Pumpkin pie
that I can't wait to dig into.
It smells fucking fantastic.
Stick. That's a pumpkin pie and
it's a cream pie and apple pie.
It's really smells fucking awesome.
Oh yeah. It's a butter baste crust.
I switched over,
I switched over.
I used to buy parents. The
one that we grew up on was,
was shortening, like Crisco.
Right. And I thought I had
too much salt in it and stuff.
So when I bought the big green egg,
which is this insane thing that you
some possible to fuck up on. Yeah.
I'm actually learning how to smoke me guy.
This guy,
he's been helping me out and uh,
I just been on the road,
so I'm going to try starting back up
again, um, this month. But, um, they,
I came with this giant cookbook,
like I made this Turkey pot pie
and everything that tastes good.
Fucking insane from scratch.
Yeah.
But the crust is on the one from the
big green egg as a recipe that I use,
which is two scoops of flour and
eighth of a teaspoon of salt.
And then it's like a
whole stick of butter.
And then there's a little bit of
shortening, like the Crisco Shit in that.
But it's, so it's not like a mine
was, it was too greasy, too salty.
This one is like that flaky, that
fucking awesome crust. And yeah,
it's the best.
So you're like,
you're like a chef,
you're like actively cooking was like a
regular thing. Faker. Bill Baker. Yeah,
I like it.
I liked it.
I liked like degrees of difficulty and
I actually learned a lot back when the
food network was awesome.
Like the food necco networkers going on
the same trajectory that MTV went on.
You know what I mean?
Like it started off MTV was music videos
and then now I don't even know what the
fuck it is. It's teenage pregnancy.
There's no music on anymore.
The food network used to be top
chefs teaching you how to cook.
Now it's a lot of just, you know, they're
fighting, competing with each other.
Like I don't even know.
I don't even know what goes on in this.
And it's a lot more personality driven
like that diners driving and and dives
guy, you know what I mean? Like that
is what is an easy just, you know,
he drives around to the greasy spoons
and he lets you know is what's up and a,
but dude, the guy's restaurants
get horrific fucking reviews.
Like just like one of the most epic
slams have any fucking restaurant that
opened was very, yeah, yeah. That
guy. Yeah, that guy. So like they,
they went more in that
direction where they,
they went from guys just knowing
how to cook until like Guy Fieri,
he's got to look, he's got bleach blonde
hair, he wears his sunglasses backwards.
We have them drive around in the car.
I'm not really shitting on the guy,
but they, they went more like that and
they tried to like, you know, it all.
And this is okay. So
Rachael Ray pops up. Okay.
We've got to find another one
of those. You know, it just, I,
it was really sad to watch cause I
used to just watch molto Mario was my
favorite and he would just be
in a kitchen and he would just,
what was any of these people? I, I
heard of the guy from here. He got him.
I met him. He's a based really how
he's a beast. He's a good dude.
This guy would be like, I'm trying to
compare him to a fighter. Jon Jones.
He'd be like someone who held the belt
for a while, you know what I mean?
Anderson Silva of cooking. I would
say that. Or maybe JP do you have,
what is it nearby? I'm not good
with the fire doors. Saint Pierre.
George Saint Pierre P of cooking.
Although he was early on.
So I think maybe he's more like
those guys when it was foreign.
It was literally taekwondo versus a boxer.
He came on early.
So that's the guy. Yeah. So you
were, that's an unfortunate picture.
It's just a highlight is
mole. Yeah, he's um, he, he,
so he used to have the show multiple
Mario and it was just him in his kitchen.
It was him in his kitchen.
And He, Oh God, he needs,
he needs somebody to take better pictures.
So what sausage are on the next?
A great look. Yeah, it's supposed
to look like a scarf. I don't know.
So he would just have people over in
his kitchen and he would make authentic
from scratch, just uh, uh, Italian
meals and he went over to Italy,
learned how to cook.
He can tell you about all the different
parts of Italy in the rivalries that
they have over there with their food.
That's why Italians are the greatest
fucking cookers ever. Cause like they,
they get upset with shit
like sauces and stuff.
The way other people kill each
other over like their football team.
You know what I mean? Like
they just don't, oh this,
this part doesn't do it right.
This is the way we do
it. And, um, I learned,
I just watched him making these
meals and it would be like, he would,
each little part of the meal would have
the three or four ingredients and then,
well,
however he was getting it going and then
it would all come together and he would
just be shooting the shit. Talking about
Italy as he made his friends a meal,
which is the greatest thing he could have
a fucking deal was cook for somebody.
I think one of the grace. Um, so it
was just a simple show. I used to,
used to come on at like noon time.
I watched it every fucking day.
I would wake up after doing
spots late at the, uh,
the seller and all that mural
back I was living with like, uh,
I was after I lived at Bobby Kelly,
but you know,
we'd stay out late and shit and I
would sleep til like fucking 11.
I would wake up and rather than,
than watching like the prices right or
some shit, I would just pop that on. And,
uh, I, I dunno, just watching him
was interesting and then I learned,
I just learned how to cook, you know,
making fucking a pasta from scratch.
His well method. You make pasta from
scratch. It's not hard dude. Really.
So you do the flour,
the eggs everyday it's having the balls
to just allow yourself to fuck it up
going like, I'm going to fuck this
up. Like I made a key lime pie and a,
I fucked it up because they
want a little bit of the,
I think it's called the Rhine,
which is just a little bit like the zest
of the lime and I didn't know what I
was doing and I went to Tepe too deep
and I got to the white part and that's
when it gets bitter and it fucked the
whole pie up. And I was like, ah, fuck it.
I had to throw the thing out. But
then you know, it's, you know,
it's anything if you just fuck it
up and then fix it, it's like, uh,
if I had the time, you know, I would
learn how to rebuild an engine on a car.
I love watching those shows, but like
on, I've always thought like, you know,
I'm going to buy like a
fucking 82 Chevy citation.
Just some fucking hunk of
shit. Start with that. Yeah.
And well just cause I don't give a fuck
about it and you can screw up on that.
Like I tried to learn how to rebuild a
carburetor and rather than doing the one
on my truck,
the 68 f 100,
I bought the same carburetor off of Ebay
that was fixed and I just took it apart
and then try putting it back together.
I fucked it up.
That's still something that bugs me.
It's sitting in my garage like in pieces.
But like did you take lessons or do you
just try to figure it out on your own?
Youtube,
just youtube to drum lessons.
I take those but like a
youtube and shit like uh,
there's certain things like I would
take a cooking class or something,
but most of my fucking add
like the Internet is perfect
so you could shut it off
when you want to.
Tying and read about the Illuminati and
then I'm learning how to make a pie.
And then I'm watching a bear
fight and eagle just like,
like fucking the Internet was made for
fucking add psychos like me and I just
will literally just fly through all of
this, all of that stuff. And um, I've,
I've learned to like,
I didn't think I had add then my wife
said I had it and then there was that
whole woke, should you fucking,
you know, do something about this.
And I just really realized that,
uh,
I just got to learn how
to make it work for me.
So what I always have is I always
have like nine things going at once.
You know what I mean? Playing drums,
learn how to play a helicopter.
I'm make a pie from scratch,
but the over to over.
The thing is the fucking comedy.
But the thing is,
is doing all of that and fucking up and
failing and all the people that I meet
in these different parts,
you know,
hobbies and shit ends up informing
like characters and shit when you or,
or points of view and stuff like, you
know, like shit I used to buy into that,
you know, the flyover states, people
down the south, down south of dom,
all that stupid shit that people on
the coasting and then you go there,
you're like, wait a minute,
these people are fucking cool.
They're doing different
things. So um, that's how,
that's how I got into like
barbecue and smoking and stuff.
So like when I go on the road, I tried
to do that. That when in Rome thing
it's different now. Lemme think when
we were kids, when we were kids,
I think that was more applicable but good.
But the Internet is informed more people
and sort of educated people in a way
there. There's this cool
place people everywhere you
are now. Yeah. But it also,
it depends on how you use any
information you get. Like, if you,
if you just wanted to reinforce it,
like the joke I was doing,
my act as everybody just
goes to [inaudible] dot com
and just reads a bunch of
facts and then just throws it at people.
But I mean I'm guilty of that too, but,
um, I dunno, I have faith,
but like watching the kinds of people
that have been coming out of the woodwork
and this latest, uh, election, you know,
a couple of those guys like watching,
um, ted Cruz now just watching like,
um, I would say, uh, what's his
face? They had Donald Trump,
the way he bullies the media and when,
what pussies they are,
how they just backed down.
They really just back then all you gotta
do I ever know that you just got to
give him shit back.
He just like gives him shit and they just
stay fucking there and take it. It's,
it's not at first it was funny to me
cause I used to love watching a bill.
Parcells was one of my
favorites to watch when he,
when he would do a coach for the
giants, patriots, uh, cowboys,
munch a bunch of places he was at, but
he would, uh, in his press conferences,
if you asked him a stupid question,
he would tear your fucking head off in
such a perfect way that everybody else in
the room was like, Oh shit,
I'm not asking them this one.
I've got to make sure I'm
on my game. Like, and,
and he took charge of it because I,
that's one of the ones where I'm rooting
for the guy because I feel like this is
a bunch of nerds who may be, they, they
played varsity fucking based. We don't,
you know, the way they come at him like,
well what did you do this, you know,
now that they know the
result was something bad.
I like when he's giving him shit,
but like, um, I just, you know,
some of the shit that just watching him,
um, I liked it. He's going back at him.
But the way that they just
are backing off him like, oh,
I didn't know he was going to make me
look stupid. They just like implode.
Like he sat there, I went
once, it was fucking hilarious.
He was not at first republican
debate. They were going,
you said this about women,
you said that about women. You said
this about women. He goes, Nah,
cause I said that about Rosie O'donnell
and it got a huge laugh. And she goes, no,
you've said that about other blah blah
blah blah. The women that he just goes,
hey, probably right. And then that
was it. And it just went away.
And I think like he's, he's
really, it's fascinating.
He's like exposing, uh, you
know, that, that, I don't know,
it's like that wizard of Oz thing
that there's just a little guy behind.
They just have the one question and
they're waiting for you to stammer.
And if youth kind of throw the,
hit the ball back in their court,
I just don't think they're ready for it.
I don't think they were ready for that
kind of a personality and politics that I
don't, but like some of the racist
people in Shit that you know,
that whatever the fuck was going
on in that conference room,
I'm not saying the black dude
was 100% in the right, you know,
and this guy went there and
started yelling some shit at Trump.
He heckled them and you know, when
did this happen? I don't know,
do you know about this?
Tammy and shit went sideways and
then there's the next thing you know,
there's a bunch of,
you know,
eight white people on top of
the black dude or whatever.
So I don't really try what happened.
I don't know what happened,
but all I know is the quote that
I read on this site was, you know,
was the politician guy. They had
Trump going like, well, you know,
maybe maybe should've got roughed up.
And it's just like, Jesus, dude, Geez,
is this sounds like I'm watching
a mob movie. It's really weird.
So Trump was saying maybe
the guy should've got rough.
I think too, like I said, I got add,
I was on like 20 different sites.
I think I have add too, but it was like
clickbait. Like I was probably, you know,
I dunno.
Here it is. Yeah. Donald Trump
on his black lives matter. Yeah.
Maybe he should have been roughed up,
but you know the black lives matter
movement, it's so strange. Oh they, they,
they interrupt shit and scream things
like you saw what happened in Dartmouth in
New Hampshire.
They walked through the study hall
while his kids were studying and I just
started screaming black
lives. Black lives. Oh,
everybody's quiet and study
hall just there studying.
There were no people. Yeah.
That's still lowest level of like
trying to get attention and not and,
and not having people want to hear
what the fuck you have to say.
Is it just going in and annoy
the shit out of somebody?
It's like those people
when they ride the bikes,
like a thousand of them get together
and they blow through lights.
Like that's going to be like,
you know what? There should
be a bike lane out here.
I just think, I wish I had a bus and
I could run over all of it. Right.
Which is why, uh, you know, I dunno,
I look at those terrorist acts like I
would think that if like a lot of the
complaints, legitimate complaints
that being oppressed, that their,
their natural resources are being pulled
out of their countries and they're not
getting the money for,
but to then blow up innocent
people go in and shoot them.
It kills you fucking message.
Do you really need is a documentary yet
by some bleeding heart person would,
I think would do way more than a dirty
bomb or whatever the fuck it is they're
trying to achieve because it
just makes you think like, uh,
no matter what that point is, it's just
like, yeah, but how could you do that?
Yeah. I think what their point
where they're trying to do,
if I had to guess is they're trying to
get people to not like any Muslims to
hate Muslims because there's
like 1.6 billion Muslims.
If they can make it about Muslims and
not just about isis or just about one
terrorist group.
And separate people to the point where
it's everyone has just attacking people
that are of Islamic faith,
right. Then they have a holy war.
I think that's ultimately, yeah.
And you can make a ton of fuck it.
There's a very few people can make a ton
of fucking money on us, a ton of money.
And they're also fucking crazy. I mean,
so it sounds, it's money, it's ideology.
They're trying to dominate
parts of the world. I mean,
money's definitely a big part of it.
Did you see that, that uh, that
documentary on Scientology? Yes. Yeah.
Amazing. Yeah. And I
watched and I was just like,
if you can't see your
own religion in this,
if you don't see the beginning
of your own religion in this,
the only thing that fucks
Scientology is this video of the two.
He just started it too late. If that
guy started it and like, I dunno,
18 hundreds, they'd still give him
shit cause it'd be a newer one.
But the fact that there wouldn't have
been video of this fucked up teeth looking
redheaded dude on some broken down boat.
Like if there wasn't video of
that, like I, I think people could,
could really see, I mean, dude,
my background, my religion,
I mean this shit that we have done is,
it just,
it's like everything that they're saying
that every Muslim is doing right now.
It's like, well, we've done
that in spades and it didn't,
it wasn't a couple of extremists
that was the leaders of the religion,
you know, Crusades, the inquisition,
the fucking pedophilia. It's dude,
they were in bed with the Nazis.
You know,
when Jews went to find
like where the hell it all,
I took my riding lawnmower or whatever.
They went up at the fucking Vatican.
Like some of this shit was there now.
Oh, is that what those yours, sorry.
Yeah, they were on both sides.
They were just like, listen,
I don't know how this is
going to shake out. You know,
a lot of people in Europe are like that.
They've always done that. You know,
there's, there's a damn cars
the chairman's make, you know,
you've got to think they're going to win.
It's just too small.
And Island is small country who was a
big country like the United States and
they made shit like that.
It'd be pretty,
one of my favorite quotes from a German
general was said one tiger tank was
worth four American Sherman tanks,
but the Americans always had five.
That's a great quote. That's what
it was. It was fucking Mcdonald's.
We were just cranking them
out like fucking quarter
pounders with chase and his
crazy. When you think about the
fact like Audi, Mercedes, BMW,
like BMW used to make jet engines,
they and that technology was in
that tank student when I was,
I mean this shit I've been reading
is like when American soldiers killed
somebody German, they dropped the American
gun and picked up the German Freeling.
Yeah, like are are machine guns I
guess overheated or there's, you know,
come on man, you like car nearing,
you know how it is. I mean we've got,
we've got the corvette,
we got a couple,
but most of them are kind
of a Monte Carlo. Yeah,
we have like old muscle cars.
What I like is I like the old muscle
cars cause the way they look and the way
they sound, but the way they drive
could be if you took like a uh,
1980s Porsche or even a seven,
he's a good to look in 1973
Porsche like a 1973, nine 11.
These they handle pretty fucking good.
They're pretty God damn good.
I mean not like a new car but pretty good.
The American,
what the American excuses is,
we had all this land so we
could have straight roads.
What they had over there do,
those were like the original cow paths
when they will bring in fucking revisions
to town and then they just paved over
and basically and then all of a sudden,
how do we go 200 miles an hour on this?
That's why you know Formula One has
right and left turns Bestival do is just
drive in a circle over here.
I love it dude. I love that.
The more I travel, the funnier
we are. Like we're fucking loud.
We got a lot of shit but were not bad.
They try to make us seem like we're
bad but we're not. But it's just,
we just are a product of where we're
from. And who's kidding who man, it's,
is it any more fun than just stomping
on the gas and go down 200 miles an hour
to straight line?
Well finally the cars fly making today
like the new z 28 or the new Camaro's,
the new Corvettes, the new mustangs,
they actually hand the Cadillacs. Great.
So much of it was the
suspension once they,
we actually put some money cause all we
would do is just be like what the fuck
and this thing hold in this engine bay,
which automatically is stupid
cause you're adding weight there.
So but we would just
stick as far as I can.
I've seen if you would
just stick that in there.
And it was all about doing the quarter
mile or something that are blowing
somebody off at a fucking a red light.
Even as recently as the,
like the 2013 gt 500 Shelby, I think
it was like a 60, 40 weight balance,
like 60% front end cause
it was all engine. That is,
it's so out of balance now that's, that's
a bad cause. I don't know. I don't know.
Wow. It's like if you want
any room, if you want it,
you really would like 50,
50,
50 fifties ideal Porsche
puts the engine in the rear.
But they do that for traction because
the engine sits over the back wheels and
it helps you get off the line faster and
it helps you when you're going around
corners to uh,
to hit corners faster.
Jamie can make some tape or the fuck
is going on with my throat. But uh,
when you want,
when you go around corners,
it helps you get on the gas quicker
because there's more traction. Oh.
And there's like a pendulum effect too
with having to wait in the back that you
could actually use and manipulate.
The guys who know how to
drive Porsche's really well.
They know how to manipulate that so
they actually steer with the throttle.
So as they're turning,
they hit the gas and the ass end kicks
out and it changes the angle of the turn.
That was a really, really bad ass
drivers know how to manipulate it.
So once again, thank God Germany
was such a small country. Right.
Did you see that normally tunnel joke?
No, I think it did it on Letterman.
I forget how it went, but it was just
something to the effect that Germany,
how small they were like
they were basically the size
of the state of Maine and
they tried to take over the world
and he goes and they almost did it.
It's fucking like, yeah, they all clothes.
It is amazing that one country
produced so much engineering.
When you look at the
automotive engineering that
came out of that one spot to
this day, the biggest car companies
in the world, Porsche, Mercedes, Audi,
BMW, all those are German.
That's, that's, that's phenomenal.
We rated their secrets afterwards,
like everything from audio taped to
are like NASA program was riddled.
Operation Paper clouded a
lot of Sauerkraut on that
paper. Well, not just ours.
The the Russians too. They took a lot of
the engineers from, from Nazi Germany to,
Oh, they did? Yeah. Yeah. There
was like a battle between there.
They're Nazis and are Nazis and
that's the operation paperclip.
There was like more than a hundred
Nazi scientists. They took over.
It's fucking crazy. The whole Nazi,
like Werner von Verner von Braun,
the guy who ran,
not NASA,
the Simon Wiesenthal Center
said that if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him
for crimes against humanity.
He was a fucking straight up Nazi.
Oh, he was? Yeah. He Hung Jews.
He hung the five slow as Jews in
front of his rocket factory in Berlin.
The five slowest workers. They
would just hang them. No wait.
So this guy was could build rockets and
he was also into that shit because I
always felt like what Germany
was like, yeah, the scientist,
you're under this flag,
so you got to work with these
guys who were going to kill you.
I didn't know that you could actually be
an egg head light. Usually scientists,
they understand that human beings are
human. You know what I mean? Well,
he might've just complied so that he could
get his rocket factory going and have
the funds and have all the necessary,
have all the tools and all that jazz.
I don't know exactly. You know how
he, how he did it, but he was a Nazi.
I mean, well, why he was a
Nazi is up to debase Christ.
How do you get out of that? It's a good
question. You can't say no. You got to
run away. Well, they can come. Can
we just do for is four cool. Cool.
Just talk him down.
Just one moneywise enough.
Oh Man. Yeah. He's a,
I mean,
obviously he was a brilliant scientist,
but they got a on a lot of brilliant
scientists they brought over from Germany
and Germany's never going
to shake that one off.
That's what going to be, that's going
to be, that's another one. It's on,
it's on like, uh, two things.
It's, it's on video, you know,
video documentation of it and uh,
and that country still exists.
You know what I mean? Scientology,
they won't let Scientology.
It's illegal in Germany. Why? Because
of what happened to them. Like they're,
they're nervous about
people starting movements.
So any kind of cults and he'd
kind of mind control shit.
Anything that looks nutty, they're like
not here foul. Not here. No data is,
are people falling. Dave Matthews I think
judge it too much. Organization, fish
vision was one that I never got.
Did you ever try to listen to that?
Uh, yeah I did. I just, I,
I had young ears when I did so I'd
have to go back and let's do it.
Like I was coming right out of hair metal,
just starting to accept grunge and
then I went to this fucking jam band.
I did see them, uh, alive. Uh,
how to fuck that. I ended up, see,
I saw them at the old
Boston garden cause it was,
it was a WBCN had this thing where they
had two stages going and they just had
all these like every fucking band,
like the spin doctors and just all of
these guys. And then fish closed that,
I forget who I wanted to see though.
It wasn't either one of those bands.
It was somebody else.
It was a long fucking time ago.
And I remember seeing them in the crowd
was going fucking nuts and they had
these little tramp, you
know, workout trampolines.
They were like jumping up and
down on them as they played
really long songs. That's what I
remember. Really long songs on it.
But I bet if I listen to him now, I would,
I could, uh, maybe get my head around it.
But that was definitely,
that's the graceful, the grateful
dead did that too. Right.
And those really long jam songs,
they just go on and on.
Yeah. Yeah. You had to go
see them live to get it.
If you were someone like I went and I saw
him at Sullivan Stadium and uh, asylum,
I'm right before they
keyboardist. Oh deed. Like
literally two months before that.
And I remember going there and
I was sorta into the music,
but watching how in how much they
were connecting with the people there.
I actually, it's like, I get this.
I get why people could get sucked into
this because what was cool was there was
a ton of people there,
but there was no violent
violence vibe there.
There wasn't like, oh,
hey, watch out for that.
Everybody was just really fucking cool
and going nuts and was like beyond
excited that they were there, but
once again, it just, it didn't,
wasn't really for me.
What was it?
Everybody on acid isn't.
That's the whole thing about those
things that everybody is tripping. Yeah.
I mean I think it's available.
I don't think literally everybody,
but there's a lot of people. Yeah. Boy,
whatever drugs they were doing, I mean,
I don't know.
Doesn't that followed them around?
When I was out of high school,
I guess she went to college for a little
bit and then her and her boyfriend just
traveled around the hit a VW bus on
those buses in a little vans and add the
back of the van.
They would sell scrambled eggs.
They would like buy groceries and make
bacon and eggs and sell them to people
that were coming in. That was
like her did. That was her gig
travel around the country
because there's a night,
there's a beauty in that simplicity. But
I think after a while you want to, uh,
like dude,
I got take
shower. I just want to be,
they want to be in a house man.
He keep swimming in the lake.
I was sleeping up in that fucking
though the roof of the uh,
the VW camper specials.
Um,
I'm fascinated by those things cause
I'm thinking about putting together an
apocalypse vehicle, like a, um,
like a Toyota Land Cruiser that
has one of those tents on the roof.
You ever seen those things? They
have these tents. They uh, they,
they packed down to just a few
inches. They're like, you know,
six or seven inches high, like not even
maybe, maybe six inches high. And uh,
they, you unzip him and then unfold
them and they come with a ladder.
So there's a platform on the top and the
platform folds over and doubles out and
extends out to the side of the truck and
then you climb up the ladder into these
tents.
I would tell you that if you,
if the apocalypse
happens and you're in La,
you're vehicle is useless other than to
hide behind when people shoot at you.
Because you know, you can't get out of
this fucking place even when it's working.
Yeah. You got to get it. So that's
why I did the helicopter thing.
That's a smart move, man.
That's another thing you do.
Like you're involved with
so many different things.
I love that you do that because it
reminds me of me and a lot of way,
and that's one of the reasons why
I think I probably have add too.
I have to be doing a bunch of different
shit. If I'm not, I kind of get it off.
I kind of get crazy, but I haven't gotten
to the point where I'm baking pies yet.
Well, you know, the holidays were
awesome when I was growing up,
so I moved so far away from
everybody. I know that, uh, you know,
I just got all the recipes, so I was
like, I want to know how to make this,
I want to know how to pass it on.
It's not hard to, filling isn't hard.
The thing is, is the crust. You've got
to get that down and just, you know,
you make two, three of them, you
know, it doesn't take that long. Dude.
I'm not a bright guy.
I'm
smoking. I've done some smoking.
I smoked the ham, smoked two hams.
I brine them.
Did you do it on the the egg?
I did one of them know both of them
have done it. Electric smokers,
but one of them I did on this, this,
I think it's a Webber. I forgot.
Forgot who makes it. But
uh, the last one that I did,
I don't want you to do that. I
just a Boston accent. I just like,
I have to do whatever. The last
one I did, I got a pellet grill.
Have you ever used a pellet grill?
No. That's the easiest way to spoke.
What it is is that they use
pellets and the pellets are like,
say if you were making
this desk when you saw the,
would they take the saw dust and they
compress it and the natural sugars in the
wood,
there's no additives.
You know they get those charcoal
briquettes and they light really easy.
It's because they're fucking soaked
with chemicals. They smell funny.
It's a flavor cancer coming
right up on down to get Parker.
But those saw does pellets.
When they compress the saw dust,
it looks like little little cylinders
and they sit in a hopper and then the
hopper feeds down into this worm drive
and the worm drive puts it into an
element and the element heats
it up and it turns into fire.
And then it's so it's burning wood,
it's just burning wood and it keeps it
at the exact temperature just varies one
or two degrees up or down. So you know,
like if you're using the green egg,
how would adjust the openings?
The baffles you have about how is the
f the green egg holds its temperature
tremendously. That does. But if now,
how's the tastes delicious?
It tastes awesome because it's just,
what finding is it? Is it
comparable to some, cause you've,
you've said that you can do it in
everything but an actual smoker. Yeah, no,
I've done it.
And I have a Kamado which is real
similar to the green egg and I,
I never smoked a ham in there, but I've
smoked chicken in there, which is nice.
It tastes great, you know, just slow
cook a chicken like you know, 200,
200 degrees to 50 and just, you
know, have some wood burning,
a little charcoal as well. But um, I just
realized this only interesting to us.
Like we're fucking disappearing down this
rabbit hole and then what do you know?
I, I'm interested in things that
people are interested in like go,
I hear you talk about helicopter
being a helicopter pilot.
I've never wanted to fucking
fly helicopter until I
hear you talking about it.
I'm like, oh, that sounds bad ass.
I never wanted to make a buck and pie
crust until I hear someone like you who's
into it.
And then I get into it.
I mean that's how I am with things like
the comics. I like that though. Yeah.
You have to be kind of gender.
I think the best comic you got to be,
if you have to have a general interest in
shit, they can't be like, I'm into this,
this and this.
And then that's fucking it.
And then you're asking to look like that.
You're going to have like two,
three fucking subjects. You're
going to dry up. Like, Hey,
I can't come up with a new hour. It's
like, cause you're not, you're not,
you're not challenging yourself.
You got to go out and try something new.
We try something new.
You're gonna fuck it up.
You're gonna feel stupid and then you,
you're going to get a story or you're
going to get something out of it. So, uh,
yeah, my, I drive my wife
a little nuts with the,
I'm trying to learn how to
fucking relax a little bit more,
but I can't like a dude. She watches
that Bravo TV man. Oh my God.
That's like housewives, Kardashians, the
whole fucking thing. Dude. And I smart.
Why does she watch that?
I literally say that to her.
No, but she, she was like this, this is,
my wife either watches this
sickest shit ever on TV. Like,
who, who's that scientist guy? The AF
African American guy. Neil degrasse Tyson.
My God. Yeah. Dude, that guy is like
terrifying. He's so fucking smart.
Just listen to the shit that he,
yeah,
that was watching that day now and I
believe we all came from the trees.
It's crazy, right? What do you mean
you believe what he was saying?
That like if people were saying we
came from the oceans and blah blah,
he had this whole theory
that, you know, the, the uh,
whatever the fucking trees grew first and
we came out of that and we're all part
I do and they're doing all the special
effects and then he fucking zooms in on
you. It's like one of the states
where I feel like, um, yeah,
like I ate a pot cookie too big
apart cookie when I watched that guy.
But she'll either watch that
type of stuff or like Fargo,
like really good TV or
she, she, she just wants,
just wants to veg out, sell how I
make my peace with it, I'm like,
this is just as dumb is me watching
every Bruins game or every patriots game.
That's good. Getting like
emotionally like, like,
like hating Rex Ryan on some level.
He's a coach of the buffalo bills.
I don't know the guy.
I'm sure if I hung out with them
he'd be a fucking great guy.
We'd be laughing our balls off,
but it's because he coaches this fucking
team that plays my team that I get
nothing from other than, you know,
fucking having a heart attack every game.
Like that's, it's really to take,
why do I give a shit to this level?
I do love sports so I
just think it's fucking
Badass. I listen to podcasts. You fucking
love sports. You go off sometimes.
I can't let,
I have to fast forward.
See when you're done talking
about the patriots. I know,
but sometimes that'll be 15 minutes,
but I get it because I, you know,
I've obviously obsessed with MMA so I
get it. I just don't follow regular.
I just don't have enough time.
I just know that if I got into sports,
like if I got into football and I had a
buddy of mine and tried to get me into
football, we watched a an awesome super
bowl game once and I was like, wow,
it was amazing.
I don't know at the time I don't have
the time to allow all the games and pay
attention,
all the shit.
That's what I always ask people when they
go, I'm not into sport. I'm like, Jesus,
I go,
what do you do with all your free time?
Because the amount of time that I spend,
um,
you know, just looking at the
standings, seeing who's doing what when,
then it makes me think
back when I was a kid,
I got to look up this player and
then I got to see like a all time.
I'm big on numbers and shit.
I love that about the Internet that you
can look up like the all time leading
pass rushers are our
quarterbacks or something and
then they'll have highlighted
the guys who was still
playing and he's like,
oh this guy's like a hundred
yards away from passing this guy.
Let me watch the game and
see if they bring it up.
But he just passed fucking slinging
Sammy Blah. Have you ever shown it
about doing commentary? Would you
do commentary of like the, I mean,
you know a lot about football.
I would do it on my own.
I would do it on my own,
but because the thing about
it is, is uh, you know,
once you like, that's a, it's a,
it's a corporation as much as you're
enjoying the sport and like the NBA,
Nfl Nhl is a corporation
and then you, you, no matter
how you slice it, you're in,
you're in the cubicle.
And I can't be,
I can't be saying certain things.
I have that same problem with the UFC,
but I've been around for so long,
I kind of get away with it in some sort
of a weird way, but probably not forever.
It's probably going to come
a point in time though,
but you don't say anything crazy,
but not during the show night.
Not during the fights,
but sometimes outside the fights I'll
talk about fighters are fights things and
I'll say something ridiculous because
you know, especially like Tony,
Tony Hinchcliffe and I got in trouble
recently because we were talking about
this woman cris Cyborg, do you know
Chris side mortgages now? Grace,
great name though. Very masculine,
very muscular, a female fighter,
excellent fighter. But she's been caught
using performance enhancing drugs.
She got caught using male hormones and uh,
Dana White was talking about
roasting fighters were on my podcast.
He wanted to set up a roast and I said,
look, Tony Hinchcliffe is the guy,
he's awesome at Ross. I go, I don't,
I'm not good at it. It's not my thing.
But he's great at it. I go, you
should, you should row cyborg.
That would be the first one. And he
goes, I don't know where to start.
I go her dick.
Like that's where you would start.
And then Tony went into
this whole thing about,
and then she got mad and she's upset at
us now and she says, we're bullying and
see it's a problem. [inaudible]
you're a Philly. Yeah, exactly.
Also know him and the people and stuff.
That's another thing too. It's like,
you know,
one of the fun things in the podcast is,
I don't know any of these gangs.
I don't get paid by these guys.
You're Conor Mcgregor rant.
That was awesome.
That guy,
he earned coming out.
I know he fucking dropped his hands a
little bit by just felt like, you know,
he was doing all right for a
guy that had the short thing.
And I'm not shitting on Conor Mcgregor.
The guy's obviously a great fighter.
It's funny though.
It's funny,
I said the Burger King look at guys came
out and attacked Barney rubble. Yeah.
No, but there's something funny
about that. Like on uninformed yeah.
Sort of thing. So like ideas, his whole
thing. He always gets the names wrong.
Yeah. Yeah. I got into this business
to not have a job I don't want to have,
and I've, I've done, I've done one gig.
We're actually wrote for a
fucking, like a, uh, like a, uh,
a comedian that was going to go out
and do the monologue fucking thing.
Oh really? And it was just fucking, it
was weird. It would just be like, okay, a,
the monologue is a little weak here. We
need more jokes about corn. Hey Bill,
go in the room and right gimme 10 jokes
about like whatever about fucking how
long ago was this? Five, six
years ago. Who we run four.
Do you remember I named it,
I am going to name names
but I just got into this,
that was waiting for somebody very funny.
Uh,
I did it like two years in a
row and it just became like a,
like a job they have,
what am I doing here?
And I have like a tremendous amount of
respect for writers now that they can,
uh,
I mean that is like,
I remember long time ago when Mr Show
was on the first time seeing Bob Logan
Kirk on stage and he was like,
towards the end of like the fifth season
or whatever they did and he was coming
in just fried from the writer's room
and he was riffing about how he goes,
you know what I do during the
day? He goes, I, I mind comedy.
I strip mine. You can just feel like he
was just like, just sitting there like,
you know those fucking shows through when
you start getting like 70 episodes and
you're like, fuck, now what do we do?
And you just sitting around
trying to think of something. Um,
don't you feel like that would
stand up sometimes? Like, cause
you, would you put out a new
hour every year and a half or so?
Every two years I'll be two
years maybe a little bit more.
Like I do it in a nice relaxed clip.
Like a,
what Louis does is astounding
to me that you could,
you could just go back when
you know Richard Pryor.
Richard Pryor did that for a number of
years. Like he put out like an hour,
like four hours out in six
years or something. And did
it every year of his life.
Every year of his life. He put out
a new hour. I mean it was, yeah,
that's astounding to me.
Louise. The craziest,
because he did it while he's producing a
show. Writing, acting, directing. Yeah.
And on a high quality, one of the funny
shows on fucking, he was editing it.
He was involved every
step of the way. No, I,
I would have a gun in my mouth with that.
I don't,
I could never sit in a fucking editing
room. I can't do it. So with uh,
the show,
you know that I have coming out,
like I actually was in the writer's
room most probably 90% of the time.
I just sat there pitching jokes and all
that type of stuff and like the work
ethic of those guys.
Like we'd start getting up to five
o'clock and we get to the last page of the
script and I'd be a cough. Thank
Christ in the guy. All right, let's go.
Let's just read through it one more time
to see what we did, see how it flows.
And I would literally be like, no show.
Yeah, I'm just looking. I'm like, God,
how do these guys do this? And then
I would fucking come in the next day.
And then the got the co creator of the
show Mike Price from the Simpsons who's
just an absolute force and
he's a sweetheart of a guy. Um,
would come in and be like, yeah, you know,
I was looking at the script last night
and I kind of switched a few things
around. It was just like, I would
leave to be like, how do you do that?
Like I come home and I just fucking poor
a scotch and I stare at the on the wall
and watch little ESPN and I fall asleep
and then we're right back at it again.
And I'm like, I, it really takes a
certain type, like, you know, you know,
this guy's a comedian are, you
know, this guy's an athlete,
like to the top level writers
and show runners like a Mike.
Yeah, Mike Price. Like they literally,
it's like you look at the guy,
it's like you had, you're
born to do this shit. So, um,
it's a lot harder than people think it is.
It's a lot more work,
a lot more concentration, a lot more
effort. And like you said, the hours,
the hours, that crazy thing. Those
guys work insane hours. Uh, when,
when you get it done and it doesn't work
and you got to start pulling it apart,
just like everybody's suing. Everybody
is like on edge. I got half. Fuck,
here we go. When you were done,
what? We were done filming,
you came to the store and you were hanging
out in the back and we were talking
about it and you were like, I feel
like, you know, I love doing it.
It's going to be hilarious, but fuck,
I could have been working on, you know,
I could've had 10 new minutes over
the time of that doing this. Yeah. Oh,
I don't know. That wasn't,
that was a different thing.
That was a different project.
It was, yeah. No, it wasn't the,
it wasn't a cartoon. No, it
wasn't the animated thing.
Now the animated thing was,
was definitely a like from
start to finish. I mean,
it took us a long time and it was
definitely tedious points of it,
but it was fucking awesome.
When we were in the writer's room is as
difficult as it was was we laughed our
asses off like every fucking hour
because it was, it was perfect.
Netflix was just like, like their network
notes were push it further. Really?
Oh Dude. It was a dream. It was all
this shit we used to talk about.
I read mentioned named Michelle.
The name is shows F is for family.
It's a new cartoon coming up
December 18th on Netflix and I'm,
the trailer looks awesome. Let's play the
trailer. Can we play the trailer? We can,
can we, they're not going to be second
o is that flex isn't gonna Pause? Well,
is that kind of work as far as uh,
that don't they need the visual too?
Well, the people watched on
Youtube. We'll get the visual,
which is a lot of people,
but the people that are watching
or listening to it only listening,
they will be inspired to go watch
the video. Oh, all right. Okay.
Now that they know
it can drive, but what I have to, I
drank White House Bear White House,
bear the one draft.
You won't want to dodge.
I was watching that now you
weren't and now you're not.
Can I hold down the fort while I'm gone?
You just kind of leave me alone with
these animals. You leave them with me,
but that's our deal.
You know where you are getting into
when you let me get in. See you
catch. Don't bother your mom today. Just
busy with the little hobby. It's a job.
Yes, fine. The job. I'll make dinner.
Salisbury steak or a pork medley.
Not that shit again. What
was that? Yummy. Hey,
grab me a cold one out of the cooler.
Tear up a little man. Hold the wheel.
I wish I had me for a debt.
I'll be right back. Stay here.
You're not moving your asked him the
spot. You understand me, Einstein.
Fuck you.
Remember the test? You Tub.
Are you an abusive parents?
Do you know what these fucking hippies.
Hi Sarah.
Running around naked soil each other.
You're going to tell me how to
be a good parrot. Jesus Christ.
Once you put your God damn clothes on,
frank focus.
No son of mine, he's going to flunk
out. I hate school. I hate my life,
but I keep on doing it.
There's no girl astronauts are vampires.
Women astronauts in the future, sweetie.
So why do you lie to the girl?
You two know each other.
He was my special afterschool helper.
Remember how we clean the kitchen?
Yeah,
you fuck the shit out of him?
You went charging your sister
today. You got that? Yup. Okay.
Anything bad happens to her?
I will come right home and
I'll put you through that.
Good.
Well have a great day princess.
It's weird. Yeah. Weird
seeing a guy like a character
with your voice. Oh, it's weird.
It's like it's you,
but it's
supposed to be your dad.
Is that supposed to be your dog?
It's an amalgam of like everybody's dads
in the, uh, in the writer's room. I mean,
certain things,
certain like catch phrases like I'll
put you through that fucking wall.
My Dad used to say that, man, my mom used
to say, I'll break your fucking legs.
Yeah.
Push through the fucking lawyer hat.
It was back then where you let people
talk to the kids that were like,
just how much shit has changed.
I remember one time my mother was driving
and my two little brothers were just
acting up and she goes, she just had
had it. She goes, I swear to God,
if you guys don't shut up,
I'm going to pull over and I'm spanking
your bare ass is right on the side of
the road. And they kept testing. Dude,
she fucking pulled over and she did it.
And people were driving by just blowing
the horns, laughing. Thought it was funny.
They just like, they were
immediately like, wow,
those kids really irritated their
mom. It wasn't like, you know,
there wasn't cell phones. Take the kids
away and give them to the state and shit.
So yeah, it takes place in like 1973
and now let me read some of the names.
And so Lord Dorrance, uh, plays my wife,
uh, Dave characters in it. Justin Long,
Kevin Farley, Joe Buck fill,
Henry Haley, Reinhart, Mo Collins,
Sam Rockwell, Gary cold.
And I say him, we got all,
we've got a whole bunch of people
that came on, uh, to do it.
So what's cool is it's serialized. So
like one episode leads into the next one,
which I was against. And Netflix is
like, no, I'm trust us, trust us.
And then the second we started
writing towards an overall arc,
it just took it to a whole nother level.
And I was,
it was not a brilliant idea by Netflix.
They just been awesome to work with
and um, they're fucking killing it.
They are just killing it.
They're killing it with comedy specials.
They're killing it with series.
This is like,
it's amazing what they've been able
to do. Well, I think that they, uh,
where everybody kinda got
caught flat footed, they saw,
they saw like what it, what it could
be. It'd be like Damon, like Mike,
my space first came out like he saw
the potential before everybody else.
I feel like he just, he
just got it. I think he was,
he was actually doing shit
on other sites before.
There was even my space from what I heard.
So like I feel like Netflix
and a lot of ways like a,
those people that get like I,
they'd say Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Fallon gets what's going on line
and that's why all that stuff he has his
guests do and all that shit cause
he knows it's going to go viral.
So he gets him on TV and if he doesn't
get them on TV then it goes on the
Internet and they, all of his clips
get like fucking like, you know,
10 zillion hits. But like there's
certain people is early on as,
as we're, you know, you know
the TV and the computer,
we're all just going to become the same
fucking thing. It's inevitable now. Yeah.
But so it's the people that Kinda
like get it.
I guess I was the only way I can put
it, they just, they can see where it's,
where the herd is going.
They took chances a long time ago too.
I did a Netflix special
in 2005 those are the,
like there was one of the first ones they
did. I would think so. Like I didn't,
I didn't even hear it. Like I, that's
back when they used to deliver the,
the movies to you, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You would,
you'd get them in the mail
or something like that.
Yeah. Hilarious. They, they're,
they're doing so much shit now.
They have that Marco Polo thing.
That's about the Mongols.
You ever watch that series? I didn't
see that fucking expensive. I don't,
I don't know how much they spend on it,
but it's a period piece and it's all,
they do these elaborate sets
and incredible fucking acting.
It's the Dave d they've done so much.
And the beautiful thing about
Netflix is when a series comes out,
you can binge watch right away. So
December 8th when this come, 1818 teeth,
December 18th when this comes out, you
can watch the whole fucking series. Right.
And they timed it cause they think young
kids are gonna like it. They're like,
well, well let's wait till
they're out of college. Yeah.
Went to the home a few days at
parents would drive them nuts.
They just want to go to the room down
and watch something that yeah, yeah. No,
it's really, uh, they're
really smart. And then, um,
I think the first one I did with them
was my first special and I remember it
aired on like comedy central and
date. Okay. And then, you know,
it gets thrown into their
mountain of specials.
You never know when they're going to
show it again. Yeah. We're in Netflix.
It was like on Netflix,
so if you saw it you could tell your
friend at work and then it was just like,
you know, I just saw them,
I was like, wow, these guys,
it's like almost like they've,
they've taken the best shit from Youtube,
put it all in one place,
you know what I mean?
But you can actually watch it cause they
take down so many movies and shit and
comedy specials from Youtube.
And um,
what was great was that was right then
when I was starting to go to Europe and
they were just starting to go to Europe.
So I was like half a step ahead as
far as my were initially where I was,
where I would do stand up.
It always felt like right after I left,
the next time I came they would be
there and then like two years later it,
it flipped where I would be getting
there right after they got there.
And then that's when my ticket sales
really started going up when I was,
when I went overseas was because
Netflix, this, this show, you know,
when we were finishing them,
they were dubbing them into like
a zillion different languages.
Like there's a clip of it all in
Russian already fucking nuts. So,
so as you see a big bump when
you did do Netflix special,
a big bump in ticket sales.
Yeah, I definitely did. And
the thing about it is, is it,
but like most things,
it's like you just don't get on Netflix
and then that automatically means that's
going to happen. It's, it's the
combination. If it's like a view,
deliver an hour that's going to connect,
um,
with people that watch Netflix,
it's going to be on there and then it's
going to start moving up and get to that
front page. And then yeah, when that
happens, that's when uh, you know,
you definitely see like a bump
and then if you just, you know,
keep coming out with good hours,
hopefully you can hang onto them.
Yeah, that's what Segura said. Segora
said it had a huge impact. So it,
as soon as he put his first special on
it just boom, everything just took off,
doubled, tripled. Now he's
doing theaters like it,
it just made it made a big impact
for them. And then a year plus later,
he just recorded a second one.
So He's getting ready to release that now.
Yeah. But the thing is
though, Tom is also a, uh,
he's a monster common. So there's a lot
of people, you know, back in the day,
like the myspace thing, hate to keep
going back to that. But it was like, well,
I'll get on my space and then I'll,
I'll sell out fucking the forum.
And it's just like, well, you're not
that person. You know what I mean?
You don't have like a like whatever that
you don't have to have a whole bunch of
shit going on at the same time. But
also like Tom's got a great work ethic,
which you do too. You know, he's always
working on new shit and you are too.
You know? That's, I think that's one of
the most important things for a comedian.
It's just a constantly be working on
stuff we all know like especially where we
came from,
guys would develop an act and they had
that fucking act locked down for decades
now. And if you're doing that then,
which when you go home you're like, Yo,
hobbies getting more attention or if you
don't even have a fucking hobby at that
point,
if you basically have your life down.
Like I live here and I drive here and
this is the jokes I tell and then I come
home. You just waiting to die.
Yeah, I think, and I think
it fucks with your brain.
Your brain gets just turns to mush.
So do you,
is this something you read about or
is this just like your instincts now?
This is all figuring out, uh, your
own mind. Yeah. How it worked.
Because I feel like when you get
into this business, like you have to,
as much as people can give you advice,
you have to figure out how
you create what works for you.
Because I used to get into brutal writer's
block and I didn't know how to get
myself out of it.
And what I do now is I know these tricks
that I use that fuck with my brain and
open it up rather than close it down. And
basically what it is is like, all right,
I see.
I just don't have anything new to say.
I'm just going to Improv
on all my existing material
and I'm going try to expand
it as much as I can.
So then this old fucking thing that
was weighing me down becomes, you know,
it's like you cracked the window,
becomes a little fresh air comes
in there and it's, it's really, uh,
you know, how your mind works is really,
you know, the vibe. Like do it a few. I,
if I was in in here and it didn't
have all these fucking antlers,
lava lamps and the mummies and tech,
there's a vibe in this room.
But if you just had overhead fucking
lighting and we were sitting at some
horrible table you get at staples
and it was just the two of us,
it would affect the vibe.
Yeah, yeah. No, I agree.
If we never addressed it and maybe we
could riff on how fucking sterile it was,
but so like,
like mentally you do the same thing is
rather than sitting there at that fucking,
you know, when I'm a writer's
block, that's what I feel like.
I feel like I'm sitting in like that
overhead lighting and it's just,
it's horrible.
So you just do go on stage with,
with like a half idea
and dig yourself a hole.
We'd have to kind of figure out how
to get out of it. I do that. Yeah.
All the time. A lot of
guys do that, right? Yeah.
I got this new thing on a Mcdonald's
of all things that I'm talking about,
just how they've,
um,
I'm trying to combine it
with like the bloggers,
how they bully people
and if you apologize,
they see the weakness and then you become
the person they're always going after.
And I feel like Mcdonald's,
that when
they started making salads,
like they,
they admitted they admitted this
wrongdoing and now look at them.
Now they're serving breakfast all day.
That was the best move they ever did.
They were on the run. They're
on that side. I had a bit
about that years ago. Like,
why don't you fucking keep
making that McChrystal,
it's the greatest thing on earth.
And he stopped having it a 10:00 AM like,
it's so true that McGriddle griddle is,
I don't, I try not to eat those two days.
That like with the pancake with
soaked and Sarah is that way.
But like the bun is a pancake can say
that this one of the worst things I've
ever tasted. I love them. I
love those things. I love them.
My kid eat them though.
I can't eat them because it's fucking
like 20 grams of sugar. It's so bad for,
you know, everybody's got
their thing. I like, uh,
I like the double
cheeseburgers at Mcdonald's.
I can't eat McDonald's cheese
burgers at Burger King Guy.
I can't eat them either. If I eat at
those places, I have to eat something,
chicken or fish.
I just know that that Burger is just,
who knows what the fuck is in
mind when you don't do that. Yeah,
I know, but it's just you start
serving salads. If he got,
I'm don't want a salad bar.
I'm not going going to get stupid place
with the play room next to it because
you're stuck. If you're stuck somewhere
and there's only one thing to eat,
like if you're on a truck stop on the
highway and it's just a Mcdonald's,
try to get something with some
kind of vitamins and it, dude,
you know what they like?
They like,
you know when like a filthy comic
decides he's going to work clean.
That's what they're doing. All
right. Mcdonald's s you work blue.
Okay. What do you see? A filthy comic
trying out for the tonight show?
They're fucking act as empty. It's like
an empty box. No, you can do it though.
You could do it, but it's not
like, look, if you're just,
if you're just being dirty because it's
punching up your jokes, that's one thing.
All right,
but if it's really how you are,
I mean how I talk on stage is how I talk.
That's how I talk.
So for me to go up there and actually to
work clean and do all of that is is me
being being a character.
Yeah.
So that's why I just went up like
I think you know, to George Carlin,
you could consider that guy blue prior.
Those guys will fucking brilliant
as bill Cosby. You know,
Bill Cosby himself as stick to me it's
like arguably the greatest special of all
fucking time.
You know what I mean?
It's a shame what he did after
the specials or before or before.
During. Yeah. I mean I guess he's just
always doing that. Yeah. I have no idea.
Do you think?
And this is something I think you and I
are the last two that he never tried to
repeat.
I feel I feel left out.
Tamara Harris says that
two parties and shit,
he [inaudible] on stage with that.
You always get some rest.
But do you think that, you know, we
were talking about your mom, you know,
w could pull you over and spank you on
the highway. Like someone could do that.
Like my mom could say like,
I didn't even realize what my mom was
saying was fucked up until her brother
goes, Jesus Christ, what the fuck are
you saying? She would just yell at me.
I'm going to break both your fucking
legs. And my uncle was like, Jesus,
don't talk to the fucking kid like
that. And then I was like, yeah,
that is kind of fucked up.
But I didn't even think anything of it
cause I was seven normal. It's normal.
Do you think
that back in Cosby's day,
like back in the 60s do you think that
that was a regular thing that people just
would roofie chicks or they would give
them Quileute or they would give them a
Mickey,
they used to call it dropping a Mickey.
Do you think that that was
like a more normal thing? Um,
I have no idea. I have no idea. No idea.
But I do know back then there was all
that. What were you wearing? Well,
what did you think was going to
happen? I made it was really, uh,
it was, yeah, dude, it was,
I mean all of that, that um,
uh, frat boys shit, all of
that reputation was earned.
Just some of the sh dude,
I,
I've talked to guys like 10 years older
than me and they tell me like half the
shit that they,
you know,
not have to ship a sizable chunk of some
of their stories with the hazing and
shit they did with chicks.
It'd be like, dude,
you guys would all be in fucking
jail, man. Long time. Yeah.
Like the 70s those guys that came
of age in the 70s I remember,
God, I can't, I'm like, I'm
not gonna name names. No. One,
one night I'm riding in a car.
It was me and another comic and this
other comic who was older and we would
drive and killing time. We started
telling pussy stories, dude,
and this guy stories
every fucking other story.
Me and the other comic or looking at
each other like, dude, what the fuck?
I remember one of his stories ended with,
yeah,
there were a lot of no's that
night. It just like, dude,
we literally changed the subject,
Jesus Christ.
And he was sitting there laughing
because like to him it wasn't,
that was what was done. So, you know, uh,
I don't any anybody that says from back
then that that was done to them after
just listening to that guy
talking about the 70s I'm like,
Jesus Christ with the 60s were like, so
I believe you know, all of them. Yeah.
I think, I think that's what I
think the behavior that people had,
if you've watched like those old movies
or men would smack women all the time.
I mean it was, uh, it was all the time.
Like someone would say something
if backhand them shut up, dude,
there was no pedophiles back then. They
will consider dirty old men stay away.
He's a dirty old man. That
guy's a drunk. He's a bum.
It was very just sort of broadly defined.
Yeah.
Like a Catholic pedophile scandal
back then was there my man,
that's when the, Oh, what was
going on? We knew about it. Right.
We knew there was certain priests
he had to stay away. I have to,
this is so beyond any of anything that I,
I even investigate.
I have no fucking idea.
I just in general,
I hear to the thing that we're basically
hairless apes that can drive a car.
I mean, I really just think that
that's what we, that's how we be.
Like when I watched,
when they first discovered
that chimpanzees like eight
other monkeys and that
when they fucking kill the monkey,
they got off on it.
And they almost like walk around talking
shit about what they did and like, ah,
I saw this thing where they talked
to this one chimpanzee how to do sign
language and within like a fucking month,
his ego went through the roof.
He thinks started sexually assaulting
other fucking, I was like, yeah,
I felt like it got its own show.
It was unreal.
It was walking around
like some spoiled star.
And um,
when I just see the behavior of those
fucking things and this, I saw one,
this chimpanzee caught this
other smaller monkey, right?
And it's standing on the fucking thing.
He's up in a tree and the thing can't
move. And rather than killing it,
it was just taken its index finger.
And his thumb was just digging
meat out of the things back.
And the thing was screaming and the
fucking chimp was getting off on like
torturing this thing to death.
And it really was like a,
it was fucking depressing to watch.
I'm like, that's what we like.
So much of that is in it. Like I
really believe that. I don't, I'm,
I'm a pessimistic guy when
it comes to that shit. Well,
I mean that's undeniable when it comes
to chimps and we are a close relative to
chimps,
but that when they found that video,
when they first started filming that
I think there was a David Attenborough
nature documentary, I might be
wrong, but when we first filmed it,
that was the first time they realized
that chimps even ate meat again.
Didn't even know. No,
they monkeys all the time.
It's like one of their favorite things
to eat and they have these sophisticated
ways of capturing it. Did
you see all that? Yeah,
the way they flush it out and everything
and then they surrounded it and then
they just get the dude and
the way they see in the end,
like they're all amped up when they
killed the fucking thing. Like uh, yeah,
like the heat, I'm like from the
asshole first. They eat their guts.
Like they pulled them apart.
Like they're hold onto their body and
they pull like there's a video of one,
like literally biting it through the hips
and like pulling it, pulling it apart,
thing still alive and that screaming it
screaming and it's got this little face,
a little face and its
little hands and screaming.
And this champ is just eating it alive.
I mean that's a,
that's our closest relative. It's
crazy. But you know what? This is crazy.
It made me feel fucked up. Just
visualizing that. You can watch it.
We can pull it up. No. Um, there's a, I
saw the back when I had to shut it off.
It was on youtube has a bunch of them now
that they've caught quite a few videos
of it now, but what's more fucked up,
his fucking hate chimpanzees know.
But those other chimps, I
think they should be able
to live, but I just fucking,
I don't want it anyway. And we'd
be anywhere near one. This Gary,
they're very scary. We
didn't, you know, we,
we had this idea that they weren't scary
because of Bj and the bear and all that.
Tarzan. Yeah. All that
stupid shit from television.
We decided that there were these
peaceful banana eating. You know,
we thought the eight bananas until like
a decade ago and we didn't even ever
hear why they're so strong.
Why I saw this whole fucking
thing is the way when they,
their brain fires a message to
whatever the nerve endings or whatever,
when they can't do, obviously they
can't sit down and like play a guitar,
like they don't have that type of thing.
It's just like when they,
they want their right arm to do things
like all the muscles from the tip of
their fingers all the way
into his shoulder, all the
way to the back or whatever.
I mean I think it using those anyways,
but like our stuff is more like precision.
Their shit is just like fucking a,
it's like a, like a defensive blitz.
Like everybody's fucking
common. So I mean, I dunno,
I just realized halfway through that it
was beyond my fucking understanding of
the human body. But everyone, like
they just say like, just giant,
like areas of muscle all just,
just enact at the same fucking time.
So have you ever seen one one looks like
without their hair, the jacked, right.
Oh my God. Pull up. Pull
up a hairless Champix.
But you look at them but they don't
outweigh you. So you feel like I,
you fucker let's, that's, you know,
no biting, no biting. All right.
I ought to be able to come out of a Dojo,
right with a brown belt in Jujitsu.
If you've looked at the fucking
weight difference. Lewdness balls.
Jesus Christ. We are the size of
the sack on that guy. Do that.
Looks like Ivan puts the
Polish Power Wwba oh my God,
Dude, look at those fucking hand on and
they know it now. I don't, I don't wonder.
Yeah, we got the side of the
arms on the fucker. Yeah,
he's probably 170 180 pounds.
It's probably like a as
big as a man, but there,
the strength they have
is just unbelievable.
I had a baby monkey on me.
Baby chimp on me wants on Newsradio.
We had this episode that
they, they brought in a bunch
of animals for the scene.
Who was our baby?
It was like two years old and this
little guy was on top of me and he just
started hitting me in the back and I
was like, whoa. Like what the fuck?
Like it didn't make any sense.
Was it testing you?
I just beat my ass is a little tiny thing.
Just decided to start beating my ass.
I mean he was little like I could pick
them up and I could hold them like this,
but I knew like just from this two year
old chimp that if he decided to just
fucking go crazy on me,
I would have to fight for my life.
There's a little two year
olds. Oh yeah, absolutely.
Two year old person beat the fuck out
of a two year old every two year old on
earth doesn't stand a chance.
Who was so slow? Yeah.
Well Finna hop like a fucking squirrel
ran up your arm and started eating your
ear. Like how far that thing would get
before you even just grab its tail. Yeah.
Like you wouldn't even know what to do.
Like everything.
Snakes just lightening quick.
Like how fucking like the fastest
hands in boxing is nothing.
Nothing compared to reptilian speed.
Yeah,
they're fucking strong.
They don't have any fat either.
There's a theory because of that.
It's called the aquatic ape theory.
They think that people evolved around
water and that's one of the reasons why
you throw a baby in the water.
They close their mouth and they hold
their breath immediately and they can
actually kind of float the float up to the
top. I don't know. Blue sappy, try back.
I've only watched videos pick shit.
People in lab coats just grabbing babies
by like the back of their pants and
just throwing them out. That's what I'm
talking about, right, that look at it.
But if you throw a chimp in the water,
they drown.
If you throw up like a baby chimp in the
water, they just start breathing water.
They don't know what the fuck to do,
but babies instinctively hold the breath.
All right.
The baby humans.
Did you see that video of those
chimps fucking with that otter or some
shit?
It smells overseas.
Zoos where they just stick
animals together that fight
because they don't give a
fuck. I don't know why. It definitely,
there's no way with Pete and shit.
And you could do that in this country
with some sort of fucking honor or Zen
China. They'll put like a
bear and with a lion. Yeah.
And then watch it as they eat
some fucking Yak. Go Nana.
Because then it makes it dick hard.
Um, that was a very stereotypical,
so this fucking honor or whatever the
fuck it was. Sea Lion. I know what it was.
This thing they kept
slapping the fucking thing,
like that thing was slapping your back.
And what ended up happening is they
got hold of one of them and they just
fucking dragged it and the monkeys were
flipping out and they couldn't save it.
Dragged it into the fucking water.
And they drowned at the honor. Yeah.
Whenever the fuck it was, it was Neil or
something. It was something like that, uh,
dragged the champion of the water
and drown in it and fucking whoa.
Dragged the fucking thing in there and
the fucking monkeys were flipping out.
And I on such a sadistic level enjoyed
that video like yeah you fuckers cause I
don't like bullies and I just
felt like they were bullying.
Whatever the fuck was in the water.
This is going to torture you or your
listeners cause I can't remember what
animal animal it was.
Cause like I said,
I was probably doing 20 different
things at once and I watched them. Um,
I don't know if he,
if he'd go on their monkey verse something
eventually you to get to it wasn't a
chimp or a monkey. Uh, I
know it wasn't a chimp,
it wasn't a smaller, it was, it was
a baby baby one like a, I dunno,
like I think it was small enough that
this little brown thing could drag it in
the water. That's the best
you're going to get out of me.
I would be the worst
witness in a bank robbery.
They had legs and they were yelling a
lot. Pretty sure they were people. Yeah,
I think they got what they wanted because
they left. Does that help you guys out?
Because a lot of those fucking videos
out there too. If you could, if you go,
you know, bear versus, or champ
versus, or tiger versus, oh,
I watched them all the time.
I watch slap fights, you know,
it's the funniest slab heights.
What's slap fights? People,
it always ends up in a real fight
or somebody gets knocked out.
It's just I stand with
my hands behind my back.
You go first and you just wind up and
slap me in the face and then it's my turn,
whoever quits first.
So there's always that one guy who slaps
with this meaty part here and catches
you on the jaw and then the
person gets knocked out. You know,
one of my favorite things is,
is the people when they scream
worldstar like at this point,
they're so excited that
they're finally part of it,
that they filmed another human
being getting knocked out.
Like the level they'd like.
I think it's fucking goes through the,
I'm sorry to you listen to I
suppose just blew up their ears.
How fucking high up in bitchy the voice
goes and they scream it like 20 fucking
times. Um, it's amazing that one site
became the spot where you would go,
wants to be there as most epic
fucking knock. It's just like,
like they, you know what it is
what them is. They had a standard,
like you couldn't just get knocked out.
You,
I'd like to base level is knocked
the fuck out all the way up to like,
I guess, you know, is that
guy dead? I mean it's fucking
insane. Some brutal ones.
Yeah, there are. There are without
a doubt. Like I have a certain,
like my thing is I like if
two people at squaring off,
they go at it and one person gets
knocked out and after then knocked out,
that's it. I can watch those. But like,
you know when the person's on the ground
and then they catch like another two,
three [inaudible]
when a kick them,
when they're down,
there's a desire of this one guy who
was drunk and he was mouthing off to all
these people and one guy stepped up to
him and knocked him out and after he
knocked him out, while he was laying
on his back, people came over,
they pulled his pants down,
people started kicking him in the
face while he was unconscious.
And then he was like making these horrible
moaning noises and guys would just
run up and punched him in the
face. Not just one. Like many,
many people did it and people die. I
don't know. He could have easily died.
He could have easily died. No, there
was that kid knocked out. That kid,
the kid square was getting
bullied by another kid.
He knocked him out and he was
like, uh, I dunno. I Dunno.
In the area where the kid
hit the classic thing,
he and his back of his head and he went
to a comedy died that happened with the
Kevin James worked with Kevin James
worked as a bouncer in Long Island and one
of the guys he worked with,
uh,
got in a fight with a drunk k Odom
knocked him out. Like I fell back,
hit his head on the curb dead
and the guy wound up doing time.
You know what I mean? He was
just stupid fucking, you know,
$10 an hour job as a bouncer and inmate
maybe shouldn't have hit the guy and
maybe shit. I Dunno.
I Dunno what happened.
I don't know what the circumstances was.
I can't picture Kevin.
James is a bouncer. He's such a
sweetheart of a guy. He can fight.
I know he can fight. He's a
tough guy. I mean you don't,
you don't think that looking at him.
But Kevin James Hits hard.
I wasn't saying that. I'm just saying he's
such like a nice guy. He's a nice guy,
but he's got a switch. Like, if people
pissed him off, you don't want to be,
he's a fucking gorilla.
That guy is, he looks at,
he's a sweetheart and he does all this
like physical comedy and laughing and
joking around. But he's like, no, I
hope of with them a long time ago to 50.
He's a great guy. Like certain people
who come like, like bouncers. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I know
they want, they want to fight
and they like, I had a couple
of buddies of mine, um,
from high school and on a slow night
they would just walk up to somebody and
just say, I, it got to go. Wow.
I didn't know that you got to go.
And they would just escort them
just cause it was funny to them.
So they pretend to be a bouncer? No,
no, no, no, no, no. They were bouncers.
But if it was a slow night, they
would just, they would just walk,
they picked some nerdy guy and
just say, listen, you got to go.
You got and just watched the guide.
And then every once in a while they'd
get somebody that would get upset and we
start fighting and then they
would beat the shit out of him.
I would just be like [inaudible] that's,
it doesn't sound like a good time to me.
I saw a guy one time at Boston, right?
He got into this fucking fight and they
the fucking,
I just came in and grabbed him and I
remember they just picked him up by his
fucking neck two guys and
just started running with him.
It was the worst secure cause it was all
these people that had to scamper to get
out of the way and they're
running with this guy.
Like I swear to God the guy's head was
like nine feet in the air and he was up
there like on. All right. All
right. All right. All right.
Screaming our right as
they're running across.
Then all the dance floor's party and
they got to the fucking door where they
were going to go out.
And the door was a typical,
was only like eight feet high so I can
shoulders and head were above it and he
running like a four 40 and just boom,
he folded in half and then they
just threw him out into the street.
And I remember even back then just
going like that was so fucking overly
excessive. And if I was running
this club I would be like, dude,
do you realize that you almost
just ran over 80 innocent people?
I mean at this point,
dude,
I'm 47 so like my idea of the way young
people think is from fucking 25 years
ago. So like, like my idea of what
like what a bouncer is and they, to me,
they would just guys,
I'll used to beat the shit
out of people and you know,
in school and now just wanted
to do it for a living. You know,
I think Kevin got the job though
because his Kung Fu instructor,
Kevin used to be a really into martial
arts and his Kung Fu instructor worked
there and he got him a job.
It was just like a thing that it needed.
I think he quit when
all this was going on.
When I was 19, I worked
as a, uh, not a bouncer,
but I guess like a security person at
this place called Great Woods Center for
Katie Murphy on the raw tour.
Did you really?
So I saw a Rodney Dangerfield right
after back to school and he got big.
I was probably right
work in there.
When you saw Rodney Dangerfield,
I was probably working backstage cause
that was when Rodney was wearing a
bathrobe was though they,
those days when his hair was like yellow,
almost orange. Did he, did he died on?
No, I think he came on a Tux.
Oh, real. I can't remember him.
I remember Eddie came out in
the blue suit, but go ahead.
Um, I saw bill Cosby there to,
Bill Cosby was there. I saw,
um, I saw Kennison there like
right after his first special.
That was interesting because
Kennison did his HBO special,
it's atrial specialist fucking
giant, right? He was the biggest cup,
but then he had to write a whole new
hour and he didn't have a whole new hour.
And it was kind of obvious like you could
see like, oh there's a lot of filler.
And I remember thinking like,
wow, this is interesting.
Like I hadn't even thought about doing
standup yet cause it's like 1986. Right.
But I remember seeing him,
I was going, Whoa, like this
guy doesn't even have that.
He doesn't have like the jokes like Carla
Beau would go on before him. And uh,
there was a couple of other
guys too, I think, but, and
Carl had a pretty good act,
you know, but calls act, his act was,
it might not have been as
good as kinnisons was back
in the day, like, you know,
during the Hbo Special Time.
But it was tight.
Like you can tell his
punchlines were solid. He knew
we were, he's going with it.
But with Kennison you could tell that he
was like kind of filling time, you know,
it was, it wasn't, it wasn't
there anymore, you know,
because he had worked for
probably 10 plus on that one hour.
I never saw a guy like so
adversely affected by fame
me because I was such a fan
of his, just watching like
he kind of was every cliche.
And what kills me is when,
right when he died was he was getting
sober and he was going to t like he was
going to turn it around.
I thought
no, he died with coconut system. Like
I said, I mean, you know the guy,
he had broken his system when he died.
He,
he's autopsy revealed
that he had done coke. He,
I think he died the ironic thing and he
was killed by a drunk driver because he
used to do that bit. We're gonna
drink and we're going to drive bottom,
pull it off. You know, why? Cause
we do it every fucking night.
There was like one of his things like
that was one of his filler bits, you know,
after it just the first shit was so good
like the homosexual necrophilia acts
and uh, the fucking
starving kids in Africa. Oh
visit clip of him early on on uh,
youtube where he doesn't have
control of the yelling yet.
So it's really just like,
you know,
cause like he learned by
the time of the HBO special,
he knew how to bring it really down
right now and start to come and then just
fucking launch it and then
go back to being quiet again.
There's a great one where you're
watching him the clip. Do you see?
It's before he quite has it figured out
and he's just way more yelling then he
needs to do. But I, I get chills when I
watched the video cause I was just like,
like this guy is like,
like noses on to something and he
has like sunglasses on, on stage.
He's got like driving gloves. It's not,
it's before the trench coat and all.
Oh I've seen that video. He has a comb
over. Yeah. He had a poodle come over.
Thank God he went to the hat. Yeah.
[inaudible] we the baret. Yeah.
And in the end he switched from the Baret
to like these rock and roll poisoned
style bandanas.
Remember he had those crazy bandanas and
it would get long and his hair was long
and the whole thing. And you've got
big, ugly fat. He got big. Nah, he just
free intelligency just
uh, I mean, Jesus Christ.
I mean that he's one of
those guys that probably,
you know his autobiography
be like 12 books. Yeah.
His biographies. Good. We called
brother Bill. It's by, uh,
his or his brother. Uh, Bill
wrote it. It's called a brother
Sam. My brother Sam. Oh,
I got to read this really good because
it talks about how he had a head injury,
like a bad head injury.
He was hit by a car when he was a
little kid and it changed him. Totally.
It's one of the things that happens
to people that have head injuries.
Like sometimes they get crazy
impulsive and they lose,
they lose like whatever personality
they used to have common. Sane. Yeah.
Completely fucking insane. It's
completely equal. But he, um,
he got hit by a car, got all fucked
up, and when he got out of it,
when he healed up, he was just as
fucking maniac to, didn't give a shit.
He's like the devil enter dem or something
like that. It was just a wild man,
just was, had no impulse
control, just was going crazy.
And it was also when he was
trying be a preacher too. So
like it's sort of fueled his
preaching. Yeah, man. It's really good.
It's a really good book because,
uh,
his brother bill is a very honest in
it and he even talks about Sam just Sam
stop writing.
It was just partying all the time.
He wasn't coming up with new
material and it talked about how Sam,
before he made it was just this machine.
It's just like he was partying a lot,
but he was also working on his act and
it was important to him and you know,
and then, oh yeah, the difference
between his first and second Letterman,
you can already see the fame thing coming
in through his first Laderman is just
fucking, it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable. The Rodney
Dangerfield one though,
when he was on the Rodney
Dangerfield special, that
was, that was it. That was a,
that was just, you know, the, uh,
the owner of a danger field. Uh,
Tony told me one night that,
you know how they used to just
let Sam do whatever you want it,
but it was just fucking crazy.
One night he went on stage.
It's probably isn't funny now because
of all the shit that's happened in the
world, but he was standing there with this
trench coat for this late night crowd,
right. Probably had half
full Dangerfield, you know,
and he's just sitting there and he
had his hands in his pockets. He just,
he just came on stage, right? And
he's gonna look at you people,
you guys just sitting there drinking,
you know, you guys on a date,
you having a good time.
He just sitting there.
How do you guys know what
I have under this code?
How do you,
how do you not know that I don't have
to 12 gauges under this fucking coat?
I could just bring them up and
just fucking blow your brains out.
And he didn't let up.
He just kept going with that and going
and going and gradually people started
getting up walking out and he just kept,
you know,
that low evil fucking voice he would do.
He just kept doing like, how do you know,
how do you know if he were just kind of
fucking looking around and gradually,
and Tony was telling me going like, yeah,
he fucking walked like half the room.
He goes, I was pissed because they
were buying drinks for everything.
But you know, hey, no, that's
how Sam wise. But uh, you know,
and ended up working out. He ended up
getting a good bit out of it or something,
but he used to like, to me what I think
is cool about that as the eighties,
just seem like it was so
much like, uh, like you know,
so many comics that were just
because they needed a warm body.
We're actually getting like
TV credits since and all that.
It just wasn't all fucking big hair.
And you know,
what's the deal with this and
what's the deal with that?
That there was actually a fucking guy
doing that. Taking crazy chances. Yeah.
Well that's one of those things.
You just go in update,
you're sick of your fucking act,
you hate and people or whatever
and you just feel like doing that,
but I never had the nerve to start
walking the crowd. I never did that.
I was like, all right, I'm
supposed to do a job here.
Ever listened to the date of the laughter,
died the dice, dice God. I love that.
I love that album.
It's great.
It's a two disc album or like a two
disc CD of him bombing at danger fields
unannounced decided as film or record
his comedy CD after he did dice rules,
right. There was the first one just called
dice, right? First one just called dice.
I first one was,
I loved
that album. The day the laughter died
is him going up to a crowd of tourists.
They have no idea he's going to be there.
There's not that many people in the crowd.
It sounds like there's probably like
50 people in the whole fucking room and
he's just ad libbing to is add living.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And I remember one guy gets up and as
he's leaving the guys leave leaving.
He goes,
you're about as funny as a glass of milk.
Like that's what the guy said to him.
That's funny is that line I just met.
My favorite one was when he was talking
about how not to get into a relationship.
Remember that bit but how, how did he do
it? He was just, I can't, let's do it.
A year is very, he's just being like,
you know, you meet some chick, you know,
you like, you take a route you wine
yet Dinah and all this shit and,
and she's not going to fuck you.
See,
just keep taking her out
until you going to fuck her.
So then as she finally lets you,
you meet her parents and all that,
you're banging away and as you're banging,
are you thinking of fuck now I'm
in a relationship with this girl.
She thinks I like her. He goes, this
is how you get out of it. He goes,
you keep tagging a and right before
you come you go, oh, okay sweetheart,
get ready for the gook.
Something like that. All right,
here comes the gook.
I remember listening to that by myself
and I literally fell off the couch.
It was so fucking gross.
And so it was just so like,
I can't even describe, it was one of
my, one of my favorite fucking, uh,
now I saw him at the,
uh,
the Worcester Centrum at
the height of when he first,
right after that New Year's
Eve special that he had 88,
89, 78. So I'm like November 88.
So it was just like, uh, you know,
everybody liked the end of 87. All
right, happy new year and see everybody.
Or maybe it was,
maybe it was 89.
It might've been [inaudible]
89 maybe it's thing,
I remember he had some special that
came out towards the end of one of those
years and I use was working in a
warehouse on loading trucks and shit.
And we were all just like,
and just one of those classic moments
back then when there was only so many
channels, so we would just
like, all right, see you later.
Nobody said I'm watching that dice
shit, but this, we came back Monday.
Everybody had saw it and just, I
was just weird. It was just, it was,
he felt like everybody in new sod
somehow everybody fucking sought. Right.
And then he became the biggest thing ever.
And um,
I went and I saw him and
there was an unknown Eddie
Griffin opened. Really? Yeah.
I mean I was thinking like,
I think, believe it or not,
I'm like a year older than him. Or you
started really young Eddie Griffin. Yeah.
Really? Yeah. Eddie's not even 50 that
guys like 46 40 saving Google a man,
something like that.
But wow.
He opened up and people being rude and
bu and I was doing the same thing. Ooh.
[inaudible] toys. Like I thought he made,
so I kind of deserve the Philly thing,
but I thought it the dice.
Were you backstage go? Yeah,
these guys really like us.
Like it didn't dawn on me like,
hey,
maybe he's friends with Eddie
and he respects his comedy,
which now I know that that was the case.
Um,
and I just remember dice came out and uh,
it was just,
it was, he came out and he did like 10
nursery rhymes that we had all heard.
So he would do the beginning and then
everyone would yell out the punchline and
then he got to a certain
point you'd be like, oh,
that's good you did your homework.
Well, I too have also been working.
And then he just busted out like
five new ones do it. And it was just,
it was the sickest fucking thing
I have place was going crazy.
There was something,
some star light star bright something.
I just remember it ended
my girlfriend's Twat.
Punk Twat is such a funny fucking
word and the place do not,
I'm telling you like murdering,
murdering this place.
I never got a chance to
see him live and it's peak.
I only saw them live once I started
working at the store and saw him there.
We went to see him live.
Me and Norton and Bobby Kelly and Anthony
from opie and Anthony and red band
went to see him live at the Riviera like
a few weeks, a few years ago. Oh, okay.
In the upstairs room. That big room
upstairs. It was fucking awesome. It was.
We were in town for the UFC.
I wasn't working on Friday
night and they were like,
Tyson town, let's call, let's go. So we
went and got a steak, like gentlemen,
went to a nice restaurant, had a great
time, had some wine, clink glasses,
got an a limo, went to the dice
show. Oh well it's fucking legendary.
That's fucking great.
It was so much fun.
But he still does like a little bit
of nursery rhymes and stuff, but he's,
he's got a bunch of new shit now.
But the thing that was different about
him than anybody else was that it didn't,
it didn't,
it was good that you knew the bits.
Like you could sing them
like a song, like, yeah,
you would yell them out like Watson,
the ball.
Oh,
everybody would go crazy though.
He was giving you what you wanted and
then he was also still moving it forward.
So it was a [inaudible] and the new new
ones were every bit as good as the other
ones and they were new.
And then you were trying to remember him.
So I remember you go to the warehouse,
tell he's got new ones,
you've got new ones. It's fucking
awesome. Isn't it crazy though?
Because back then there was no youtube,
there was that we had to like go see it
under a membership to go see it and all,
and that was another thing too
when there was so few chat.
Even then there was still
like 80 channels or whatever.
But like there was always those things.
Like nobody said,
I'm watching that Dangerfield special.
It was just all of a sudden,
Monday everybody came in and everybody,
you know,
do you see that guy
move them with the food?
Is everybody knew who fucking Kinison
was or everybody knew who d dice was. Um,
Eddie Murphy delirious.
I remember when that came out,
that came out and like
everybody just fucking side,
everybody saw it. It was, it was special.
Came out back then. It made you a star.
It was a different thing. Is today like
an HBO special today? You don't hear shit.
You, you know, they come out and
nobody hears anything about it.
Oh yeah. Have gone t vose it. She'll watch
it like 30 days later. Yeah. You know,
I finally sat,
I watched part of it and then I had to go
figuring it out. Now with Hbo Go,
you're, they're making HBO on demand,
stuff like that. They're figuring it
out. They're catching up to Netflix.
But I found out all Kennison
because a girl I worked with,
I was working at the Boston athletic.
I was 19 and a,
there's this girl I worked with,
she was a fucking hilarious,
just big Boston girl.
She was like five 11 she was hot,
but she was just fucking big,
brash girl. And she, and she goes,
all my God, this is fucking guy named
Sam Kennison. Have you heard of him?
Oh my God. He was so fucking
funny. I go, what did he do it?
She goes Comea she goes out in the
parking lot and she does the homosexual
necrophiliac bit for me in
the parking lot. She's lying
on her stomach. Oh my God.
You mean live keeps fucking in the
ass even after you're dead. It never,
it never ends is the greatest line ever.
And I remember thinking like try like
laughing at these girl wasn't a comic.
She was a fucking fitness trainer
telling me about this guy.
And then I had to go see him and then I,
I think I got it on VHS tape,
if I remember correctly. The first time
I saw it, his HBO special and I was like,
Whoa, this was a game changer. Yeah.
He was the first guy that made me think
that maybe I could do comedy because
before I would see like
Seinfeld or I would see like a,
you know,
someone who was like,
like just an evening at the Improv
type guy with the rolled up sleeves.
And did you ever notice? And
I'm like, God, it's not me.
I'm just, I'm too fucked up.
My, my sense of humor is too
fucked up. I've been too fucked up.
And then I saw Kennison I went, oh, that's
comedy too. Oh, comedy doesn't just,
just has to be funny.
Like maybe I could do it,
maybe I can do it. He was a, he was
going to all of those guys I liked.
I liked Seinfeld dice.
Kinison car leaves.
What's the Carlin ones?
I liked all of those guys.
Like basically if you were
funny, you know, uh, I totally,
I got into all of that shit,
but what made me think I could do
comedy was actually those VH one standup
spotlights. Ah, towards the end,
towards the end when guys were
doing like their fifth one,
just scraping the bottom of the barrel.
And I remember this guy I worked with,
we used to,
uh, before we'd go out, we drink
beers in his room, you know,
I go over to his house, hey, you know,
misses whatever and we fucking go in his
room and you know, to save money for,
we go out and try to hit on chicks.
We'd fucking weed drink like
a six pack or something.
So he was in the stand up the way I was
and we'd fucking watch it. So fucked up.
We would get legally drunk and
then get in the car to go drive.
This was like the late eighties and
nineties. It just what you did. And um,
we use have breathalyzers back then.
Yeah.
They just for stud that came out in
somewhere like the late eighties or
something like that,
something like that. But I,
I had the total fucking classic,
you know,
Boston upbringing where it ended with
the fucking Dui and all of that shit.
Did you get a Dui? Yeah, it's been
a fucking couple hours in jail.
My Dad came down and got me out and says,
does that fuck with you now?
If you tried to get into Canada now,
because it doesn't officially show up
on your record until you get the second
one. That's how it worked in the state
I was in. And then, uh, the second
one, then it says you got to, but what it
would fuck with this my pilot's license.
Like if you get a Dui, you'd
done silver rail. Yeah,
you had done so you got to solve it. Now
guys, can I take this thing up? Yeah.
Landon clown to somebody's fucking
house. No, you can't do it,
but you can get a pilot's license. You
can now, even though you have a Dur.
Yeah. Wait, but I mean it's not
on officially on the record. Yeah.
So if you had the second one,
if I just got one.
I think once you're a licensed pilot,
if you just get one, you just say,
just take it away. It's gone.
Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
That's a fucked up thing to do when
you're drunk. Didn't like Patrick Swayze.
You do that and he crashed his
plane trunk and then fucking run.
Didn't he do that like towards
the end? I'm pretty sure. Well,
I mean if there's ever a time to
leave the scene, I think he was,
I think it was when he had cancer. I
think like when he had cancer, just said,
well fuck it. Let's just, let's just
burn this baby down to the core.
I think he decided to
just go out guns blazing.
He did. He didn't quit smoking already.
He really went out like, uh, you know,
I can't, I didn't see all the things
he did, but he wouldn't stop smoking.
He's like, I don't give a shit. Yeah.
I think he just decided I was just
burning out. Just ride that bitch,
run into the rocks. Just take that, which
is his right. Yeah. I think, you know,
that's how he wants to go. Well,
if you don't do that, yeah,
you die eventually
anyway. Right. You know,
why not end the game when you
want to end it? I don't know.
That's fucking hardcore fatal
fucking diagnosis and just be like,
I guess what drinking,
it's hard to imagine that you wouldn't
just try to clean your life up,
try to soak some more life out,
start eating Kale and doing yoga
and going on a juice cleanse.
But the phonyness of it, you'd
probably be like, this isn't me.
I'm just doing this because of, well shit.
He likes smoking and you like drinking,
you know Christopher Hitchens, I mean
he, he died the same way. I mean, I,
I don't think he tried to clean himself
up, you know, without us. I know the name,
a famous intellectual,
very famous atheist
English guy and brutal,
a brutally honest and uh,
articulate gentleman,
wrote some great books.
He also had that socially he was,
if he had that fan of Vanity Fair
article, women aren't funny. Then, uh,
backed it up with a video explaining why
the women that are funny or all butchy,
they're all like men because women
don't need that sort of, that,
that sort of skill.
In order to attract men,
all they have to do is be nice and we
like them, but men need that. It's,
it's pretty interesting because it
got a lot of people pissed off. Oh,
I remember that. I
remember that. Yeah. Yeah.
He's like one of the four
horsemen of atheism. He's like a,
like one of the more famous of the
atheist with Dawkins and Sam Harris.
He seems like that guys like one of those
guys that gets a feather in your cap
if he goes to your party. Oh
yeah, for sure. Social Lights.
I was always fascinated by that.
Like you could make a living doing it.
I was social life. Yeah. It's
just really great. At parties.
So you just invite them and they,
what do you know?
Anybody that's an artist that's involved
in like the art scene where they have
like art galleries and people go to
galleries and you have to like become
friendly and Hob hobnob and these social
circles with people that have died,
aren't I fucking hate that shit.
I can't even tell you
how much I hate museums.
If it's a car museum or if it's
got some tanks and shit, let me go.
I'm like a little kid. If it's
stuff like that, I like it,
but I don't look at a bunch of old place.
You know you should go to the
La County Museum of art. LACMA.
I think it's going to let Ella. Yeah,
it's the fucking worst. The fucking worst.
They have a box,
a plexiglass box,
an empty box on the ground and that's
a piece of art. It's roped off.
You can't go near it. You can't touch it.
And I go, what is that? Is that the art?
That's the art. Yeah. I go,
well, what is it? Well, it's
supposed to represent space.
It's the artist's representation of the
spaces and capsuled and you just sort of
with your own imagination,
you decide what's in it and
you own a magnate imagination,
you create it cause he's not going to,
yeah, let's, let's shit, there's one,
one giant wall of videos and the videos,
it's like a guy throwing a basketball
to another guy and then another one,
there's a guy who pulls a chair out of a
away from a desk and sits down and then
another one a got plops down on a couch.
It's just nothing.
It's just people doing shit.
But it's all on like a bunch of different
videos that are spliced together on a
big wall and like this
is art, this is art. Oh.
And those big fucking canvases
where they didn't draw anything,
they just scribbled all over the place,
shit on it.
Just put paint on their chest and
rolled around on it and it's just like,
yeah man, it's so bad. Yeah.
I don't get any of that.
Like what does that say to you?
What does it say it it's like,
I don't know that it looks like the shit
I used to draw when I was five years
old. My mother would put it on
a refrigerator. You know what?
We didn't know how to draw anything. You
just take every marker, Zigzag with it.
You know Bob Kirsch is guy ones, the gross
agency. I went to a party at his house,
he's got a house in Mount,
um, um, with Aspen, you know,
Colorado with rich ski town, Beautiful
House. I mean fucking staggering house.
And he had this piece on the
wall and I literally said,
it's is something this kid made like,
cause it was framed and tell them
it's awesome. Can they go? No,
no, this is a food. You
have goals. They go,
that's like $25,000. I go, you've
got to be fucking shitting me.
This is just cost $25,000 or whatever
it costs. It was so stupid luck.
And it was like a bunch of pieces of
paper that were crumpled up and painted
different colors and they were glued onto
a piece of paper. Oh Dude. It's, it's,
it's bullshit. Fucking bullshit.
Total bullshit. But why,
why do people buy into it?
What is it?
Because what makes that art and
the difference between of a kid?
Because a kid can't sit here and
draw you how you sit. Right, okay.
But those guys can and they
choose not to. That's, that's,
that's what's in the brochure as to why
that's the brochure as far as like their
philosophy. Like they're
bored, man. Withdrawn.
They didn't want to fucking
draw faces anymore. Yeah.
So they want to fucking do some
abstract shit. It's like high,
but you got to kind of
keep the face there.
You want to drive like drawling some fun
house, Mirror look and face, that's fine.
But if you just want to take every
color and your crayon box and just start
scribbling around,
I mean more if you can get some asshole
to pay 25 grand for that. All right,
good for you. Good field. You know? Well,
how does one guy like that get
super famous? Like Jackson Pollack?
He's a perfect example.
That guy just didn't even watch the movie.
It was an interesting, I love Ed. I love
Ed Harris, but I didn't even see them.
I don't know anything about the gun.
I just don't give it.
Somebody takes a paint brush and then
splatters. Yeah, it's shit. It's dog shit.
But they sell for like 1 million bucks.
Like a,
an original Pollock is worth a
fuck load of money. You know why?
I think when you have shit like that,
it makes people think that
you're intelligent. Worldly,
your culture and the colors, man. It's
like a, it's like a warm kind of thing.
I don't get it. I don't get it, but
I do get it when people collect cars.
Like I went to Jay Leno's place.
If you've been at Jay Leno's place,
I'll take you. You want to go? Yes. It's
the craziest shit ever. He has a leather,
he has 11 buildings. What kind
of pie does he like? What?
I bet he likes pumpkin.
The pumpkin smells wonderful.
He's got 11 buildings filled with cars.
The Dad,
I totally get like if you're gonna
spend your money on shit that,
I told him he could have his own
traffic jam on the four. Oh fuck.
He could have his,
I mean,
it's legitimately better than any
car museum I've ever seen in my life.
I've been to the, what's the big one
off of a set off libray Anderson.
Is that the Peterson? Yeah, I've
been to the Peterson. It's very nice.
Nothing you can't fuck with Jay Leno. Jay
Leno has got way more, way more space,
you know,
as a sick car collection.
A Ralph Lauren doesn't unbelievable.
Like they were doing a thing one time.
Uh, they were having this debate, our
cars art. So the whole thing was, uh,
they were taking Ralph Lawrence
or our fuck you say his name?
He said Lauren Lorenda
rain. Lauren. Ralph Lauren.
Wait, no, he's probably
fucking Italian. Um,
they fucking, we're trying to figure out
how to get his cars into this museum.
It was one of those museums in New York.
Can we get up to the second floor?
So half the documentary was
about, you know, just the,
the physical endeavor, the,
the physics involved with the crane.
They had to create to get these fucking
cars into this museum without damaging
other pieces, without
ruining the integrity of the
structure and all that shit.
But in the process they were showing his
fucking cars and did a brief interview
on him on how he comes, you know, how we
get to ideas for his clothing line. Um,
off of like the lines of like,
these dude he had all like,
it was all like Ferraris, Lamborghinis
like, Oh wow, look at that deck.
Whatever the fuck that is. I mean it's
just like old and old Jaguar I think,
but I don't know what it isn't that
the, what is it on the back, right?
What is it you, the whole website for
it, Ralph Lauren car collection com.
All right, so flip through a couple of,
yeah, if you don't mind. No, please do it.
Whoa. What the fuck is that? Yeah,
it's all like Gotti [inaudible] 1938
and it's all like pristine that Bentley
1929 Bentley.
God.
Well wait till you get towards newer
shit. Really? That mercy. Hold on.
Backups to that Mercedes.
Look at that thing. 19 Whoa,
look at that. It's
amazing. 1930 count count.
Trossy oh that's the sound of the engine.
Oh you click on and you get the Sally
and this is why their tanks were better
than ours. Look how pretty that
are shit. 1930s it's like, oh God.
Oh God,
whoa. Look at that thing. An Alfa
Romeo from 31 that's fucking beautiful.
And the whole thing is, it's all mint
condition too. Like if they have like,
you know those old leather straps said
held down the hoods like Oh dad's not
even like a piece of thread hanging out
of it. Look at this fucking 55 Mercedes.
Yeah, those are worth of baby
boomers. Paid like over a billion.
Like $1 million for those. The
gullwing Leno's got one of those. Oh,
he's got everything. I've watched almost
every video on that Jay Leno's garage.
It's amazing. It's fucking
garage is amazing. No,
cause he's got the sickest cars and he
knows about him and he brings people in.
You know, he had like Carroll Shelby
in there and just rest his soul. Yeah,
he's got everything.
Jay Leno's got several cars that are
worth more than a million dollars and he
keeps him at the airport.
But the Burbank airport because homeland
security guards the airport and he's
like, if alarm goes off, they
fucking move in with tanks.
Like they don't fuck around.
That's amazing.
That Ferrari click on that for are you
just had right to the right of that write
to the right of that. Look at that.
God, look at that fucking thing.
1962 gen is one of those, I read
this book one time called the limit,
the limit. And it was about, uh, the
first American Formula One racer,
uh,
that one that won the Formula
One championship and that
they would just talking
all this shit that they Ferrari would do.
Like if you had like a,
for some reason,
like if you're going to race in the race,
they had to make a space,
a certain amount of the cars available
to the public too. Oh, it be hopped up.
So what they did was they were acquired
to make a hundred of this one car and
classic Italian.
What they did was they,
they just started numbering them at like
63 and they only made like 37 of them.
Now the car is like super, super
rare. They just acted like that.
They made 100 of them cause they didn't
come down and check it out. They're like,
yeah, there's 67 there's 83 there's
number 100 over there. All right,
see you later.
No one ever said,
where's number one through fucking 50 or
what are they started number like they
dig knocked off like 40 some cars.
But uh, the book, the limits, unreal.
Like just as far as the fatalities do.
These guys have become a flying by and
like the crowd be standing on the side of
the road behind a rope and some of them
would get hit and they just go into the
crowd and just kill people.
Oh look up.
Dak count by von crash
or something like that.
They have is fatal accident
on the fuck on Youtube.
He just goes into the crowd with his car,
takes out a whole row of people.
He's still alive.
And he ricochets back out and said the
track gets t boned and then I think
ejected from the car. I'm not sure,
but the, the, the American guy,
when he got his first Ferrari,
oh, hey, go watch this
to the crowd and killed.
Yup.
What's the slow motion? Oh,
this is a, from the SPEC.
Somebody who died, that
person died. Jesus Christ.
Well,
those cars,
they're so primitive and the way they
can handle and the way they moved and
broke, like when you, when you lost, I
think that's him flying out on the left.
That might be him getting thrown from
the car. Dude, they got another one.
They got, oh dude, they got some
sick. It was that him laying there.
Fuck Dude. This some sick
ones. There was like a,
this one guy who went to a spin in his
fucking hood came off and Doug went to
the crowd like a Chinese star.
And just like the capitated a whole
row of people like that shit like that
happened.
Um,
did you ever see Lamon the Steven
Queen Steve McQueen movie there is,
you saw him laying in the road.
These are all the spectators and shit.
All the people that got
killed. Yup. That's horrific.
Look at that guys limp arm hanging
onto the stretcher. Yeah, no it's uh,
so anyways, so the American
guy, when he first gets the car,
the last driver had just died in it and
there was a fucking hole drilled through
the floor pan because the guy got the
capitated and like bled out in the car.
So they just drilled the hole in the
bottom of it and drained it out and we'd
talk about primitive.
You'd think that at least weld that over,
cause you wouldn't want the air to get
in it for like that extra a hundredth of
a second. But they just, that's
how he got the car. Whoa.
That's a fucking sick book. Do they
drained it through a hole in the floor?
Well it was so much blood in them. You
know, Jesus Christ books called the limit.
I've got to yet it did you
see Steve Mcqueen, that movie?
Lamanda have you seen
that? Long, long time ago.
It was like the eight o'clock movie.
Good fucking movie.
They don't even talk for like the first
10 minutes of the movie. It's amazing.
They go through all these things. People
do things. They're just doing stuff,
setting things up. Nobody
talks. It's amazing.
It's like those old movies
was just so different.
So different with what
they could get away with.
Like the attention span that people had.
You know?
It was a little booklet that I saw
bullet recently too. That's another one.
It's like long scenes where no one's
talking like there's this whole chasing
which Steve McQueen is running after
this guy in the airport. No one talking.
Yeah, just one thing after another thing
and it's just, it's kind of realistic.
It's just, it feels different. Feels
different than what you're watching today.
I liked that old shit.
Although I'm trying to get into new shit.
I'm sick of being the guy that likes
old shit because it's such a pain in the
ass to keep it going. I get
home, I got old drum kits.
I got an old truck.
I bought this old lighter at a,
sent it to some guy from Michigan.
This stuff, the old stuff is,
there's something about it
that you just can't like
new things are cool. Like a Tesla.
Those are cool. They're cool to drive.
They're cool. It's new. But
that 1968 truck you have,
there's something about that too. Oh
it's cool. But we know what it is.
You know what sucks is when
somebody fucking, you know,
you just how much I have to slow
it down just to go around a turn.
I just feel like it's not like that
the suspension is so primitive on it.
Like I feel like it's
gonna it's gonna tip over.
So would you consider putting a modern
suspension on it or would you want to
keep it original? Um, I for the longest
time when it, cause then when I got it,
it was all original three on the tree,
a drum brakes all the way
around the original radiator,
the whole fucking thing.
So since then I put an
aluminum radiator in,
cause those old ones ran a little hot.
Titus, uh, showed me how to do the front.
He basically did the breaks,
but I did one side,
he was just telling me what to do.
So we,
I put it yourself really
disks on the front. Yeah.
Tightness is a fucking nut with
that shit. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
he's a born to do it man. He's just,
he's fucking great at. Um, but then,
um, so you change the brakes,
change that. Yeah. But then,
but then what happened too was I needed
leaded gas and it was a fucking pain in
the ass and somebody had put too much
unleaded and I put a little unleaded in
there. And what ended
up happening was, uh,
the vows got little gunked up and uh,
ended up cooking the valve.
So I just said fuck it.
And we rebuilt the whole thing ice
and let's say we extend it to a guy,
he rebuilt the thing from the crank
shaft all the way up to the carburetor.
And uh,
they came with the auto light to barrel.
I now have a Holley four barrel on it,
which is cool cause the
barrels are actually smaller.
So when I'm just cruising around,
I get better gas mileage.
But if I step on it and
get that extra, yeah. Yeah.
So you get from a four barrel.
Yeah. So it's um, I love,
I, I like fast and loud too. One of
my favorite fucking shows I watch,
I watch all of those shows.
So many of those shows that are
trying to be fast and loud. Yeah.
So it was just like, I just wish that
they would, you know, cause you know,
it's television, they're like,
all right, this is the formula.
We got to have this guy,
we've got of the Richard Rollins guy and
then we got to have the level, you know,
it's just, I, I wish they would just
be themselves and like, you know,
everybody builds different types of stuff,
but like [inaudible] at it like an artist,
they're looking at it like they're just
trying to make widget. Yeah. Yeah. Like,
well these widgets or selling, if you
make them orange and this side, it's like,
I was devastated when that paint Guy Casey
left. I was like, fuck I, I see left.
Yeah.
Shit as you make it fun of me
now he left, but he did. He, when
they let him, when they let them,
when they let him do his fucking thing,
he did a lace top one time.
That was the shit. He did another
one. Then they'll make an a low rider.
Like when they would let him rather
be like painted green, paint it black,
you know? Uh, like I really wished that
he had done more. They'd let them do more,
like to tone shit and stuff.
I like,
that's funny.
It's funny because you're,
you get upset at your wife watching
Bravo or if you're watching this guy,
I would appreciate it if he
did more as a fucking artist.
He's not some fucking horror
walking around making a
porno. They go, how dare you.
You know what if I had some place to go,
I'd walk out on this podcast right now.
I just turned my phone on
because I want to show you this.
I bought this thing cause I'm also
a fan of old movies, so I'm free.
Bogarts one of my favorite favorites
and I was watching this thing, um,
on a,
the Maltese Falcon and
he's got this thing,
this cool thing that beginning when he
goes to light the fucking cigarette. Yeah,
it's it. Yeah, I know what
I thought it was a match.
He stuck in there and I thought it
struck it, but it's actually, it's a,
it's a metal one with like a little bit
of Flint or something on the end of it.
It's called a Ronson touch tip lighter.
And I actually,
I bought one and found a guy in Michigan
that rebuilds the whole things for you.
Really? Yeah. I got this things
foolish shit. Jimmy Polish it up.
Ronson touch tip lighter. Yeah. Oh,
here it goes. This is from
the movie that, yeah. Yeah.
All right, now watch you watch. Just
say Humphrey Bogart. Maltese, Falcon.
Good. And uh, I guess lighting
is, Oh, that's it right there.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want you to say,
Huh? How fucking cool is that? I just saw
that. It was like, what is that thing?
I got to get one.
Do you use that to light cigars?
Yeah,
I have it more just as a show piece.
Every once in a while I
got a real cigar smoker
comes over. Um, I, I'll be like,
oh, you want to see some cool.
And I'll actually break it out.
The real cigar guys though,
they want to use a lighter.
They don't, they want to use uh,
a match that's a would match.
And then they want to light a
piece of Cedar and then they light.
So none of the chemicals and to the end
of it, they get really crazy with it.
Absolutely they do.
Yeah.
I have a locker with my business
manager at a, one of those, uh,
schmancy places. Yes, I do.
I've had one for 10 years.
I've got the same Cuban cigars in there
for 10 years. Anytime you want to go,
let me know. All right, here we go. The
Havana Room. Here it is. Oh really? Yeah,
I'll definitely go.
Let's go. So here it is.
Yeah.
Oh Wow. That is pretty cool.
His neck. Now, does it put
any flavor on the cigar? No.
No. Not that I could tell, but I'm not
the greatest when it comes to that.
I like it. So, uh, all I know that if
you get, if you find a real cigar smoker,
they think it's the shit they did. They
have all these different ones out there,
but I got some cigars here with a dried
out there from that Michael Dowd Guy
who's from that. Um, the documentary,
the seven five, they just,
we just left him here. We didn't
put them in a human door. Peanut,
that documentary is depaulo toward,
turned me onto it.
It's a crazy documentary about police
corruption in like the 1980s in New York,
like during the crack epidemic
and a, these guys are just
fucking addict control,
just completely out of control.
It's a crazy documentary,
but the one guy keeping all the money
and Shit, oh, just not just that,
just robbing people,
being involved in drug deals and
just could just fucking insanity.
But one of the guys,
Michael Dowd just got out of jail a few
years ago and they put together this
documentary and uh, you know, now
he's, he does podcasts and shit.
And he came on.
And you know, it's funny when you
go to jail for some serious shit,
when you get out,
there's like two jobs you can get.
It's either you can get into sales,
you can like sell cars,
they don't give a fuck. Or you get
into entertainment cause or like,
or you go back to crime.
But Dude,
you could literally come out from
a double murder for some reason.
They let you out. You could just
go sign up for a fucking open mic.
And it's like, no, there's no background
check. He does. You're in show business.
That's true.
Yeah.
I've never heard of anybody coming out
of jail for murder and going into, uh,
into comedy.
Have you?
Well, there's a, there was that one guy
who, uh, I don't know his fucking name.
He would, I want to say he
was on, uh, the fuck show.
Was he on him and him being on Letterman?
They were talking about,
he got into a fight
and he killed somebody.
He went to jail and then
he got out and was, uh,
oh shit. Don King, Don King,
donkey and killed two people.
I have them in one.
I know he beat somebody to
death. Yeah. One of them,
I think he was acquitted for one of them.
I think they just,
they decided it was like self defense
and then the other one was a manslaughter
charge. He beat some guy to
death that owed him money like a,
when he was a loan shark, I think he
stomped him to death. I interviewed him,
I interviewed him for the UFC.
He was true.
I don't even know if it ever got anywhere.
I don't know if the UFC ever did
anything with it cause I never saw it.
But it was a crazy interview man. He just
doesn't answer questions like you go,
okay, so what was it like, you know, Blah
Blah Blah. He'll go only in America can.
A man of my fortitude in magnitude
and cum laude had come down from,
what would deal with today is
equality between the racism,
the sexism and women
today does suppress it. I,
I'm a feminist. Like he's like,
he's got this crazy thing,
he's covered with flags and he's
dripping with diamonds. I go,
I mean like covered with gifts
since one man show. Yes. It's
amazing how grades and it keeps,
keeps calling don kick.
Yeah. Piece of shit. Oh,
was me under a million die. He sounded
like a comic. Talking about club owners,
that fucking piece of shit. He
fucked me on this Gig. You know,
you never forget either.
Oh, I'm $100 million. Is that what he
owes him? Something like that. Who knows?
Who knows?
But I asked him like,
what is it with all the gold look was
not gold and platinum or white gold is
just covered in diamonds.
Just got like literally like hundreds of
thousands of dollars in diamonds on him.
And he's like, that's for the ladies.
The ladies love it. They love diamonds.
Diamonds are a girl's best friend. He
just got an anecdote in a, in a, you know,
a saying for every single thing.
He's just prepared and ready to go.
But you never get to the real guy.
You know,
you just get the show
like that at that time.
But you don't ever get to the
real guts old school. Yeah.
Oh yes. Old School. Well,
he's as old school as it gets. He's his
old school was a guy. Kills people. Yeah,
we did. There was a fucking
loan shark. Well, there you go.
I want to talk to you about Madison Square
Garden. You did Madison Square Garden.
What the fuck was that like?
Oh, it was amazing. It was
fucking awesome. It's crazy.
I got my money's worth because we,
I rented a drum kit and some amps
and me and my friends came in.
Guys from the Goddamn comedy jam,
we came in and Ben Bailey,
which is hilarious because I wanted,
me and Ben have been trying to get
together to play for fucking ever.
And I find like, Hey, I'm in New York.
You want to come and play? He goes,
Ben Bailey, Ben Bailey,
cash cab, cash cab.
Now you don't want you to stand
up comedian in New York guy.
He never lived out here.
So, um, what's cash cab?
Cash cab was a TV show where like you'd
think you would get into a taxi cab and
then, uh, you got it and all of a sudden
you weren't like a game show. Oh really?
Yeah, and I asked him about it
go, did anybody ever get pissed?
Because they were going to the airport
and he'd laugh. He'd go all the time.
They were like, dude, what the
fuck? I don't got time for this.
I thought this was a real cab,
but he had to get like his real taxi
light hack license and all that type of
Shit's really interesting that
the whole thing. But anyway,
so we went in there like fucking from
like two 30 to four in an empty Madison
Square Garden. Like we just
fucking played all this arena rock,
motley Crue guns and roses
and film some of it. Sure.
What are you gonna do with it? Oh,
it's just for me, man. I says, oh,
you gotta be shut on
youtube now saw it said,
we can tell me I suck at my hobby
because it's a horrible people who like,
you will think that's fun to watch a guy,
they'd like doing something that he always
dreamed of. I'll say, I want to see it.
I'll show you some pictures. I
want to see it. Um, it, what is it,
like 14,000 people in there,
something like that.
But what was cool cause I went in there
and we played there that it wasn't
intimidated.
Like I felt like I kinda got in there and
I got the feel for the room. Ha. Right,
right, right. And um, and when I went up,
I see the lights were in my eyes,
so I couldn't,
I couldn't really see anybody, so
it wasn't bad. It was weird dude.
I was oddly not nervous and I went up
and I had a great time. I was like,
after we played, I went
back to, um, I went back to,
uh, showing them pictures
right now. That's awesome.
A smile on your face. Oh
yeah. Oh that looks so cool.
So yeah, it just went back
to my apartment, you know?
Right after that you keep harming
in New York. Got, yeah. Do you,
how often do you know why I bought
a place back there long time ago.
And you just leave it there? Well,
I had a tenant for awhile. Uh,
I was renting it out to de Derosa and
then once he left it's like I don't want
to deal with having somebody else
like I got to think paid off.
It makes me a local hire.
If I ever get acting work,
they don't have to put me up in a hotel,
although that's never fucking worked
out for me. I never get a kid.
Everything shot in like fucking New
Orleans now. I'm trying to find this.
There is a,
there is a clip here somewhere.
We just had, we just had the best
time at was. It was fucking awesome.
I'll play it for you when it's off
the year. That sounds like a fun gig.
It sounds like it's one of those gigs.
It's like get an iconic place to perform.
It's not just a regular
place. Yeah, no. See it's,
it's definitely totally
lived up to the hype,
but I went up there and
I did 90 minutes do it.
I did all of my jokes and I said at
one point that I wasn't going to leave.
I didn't feel like leaving,
but I did record it.
I'm going to do something
with the recording of it.
I don't know what yet. Um,
like an audio recording or video? Just
audio. Not the video thing. I just,
I don't know. It's just little
me on that giant stage, you know,
the fucking 200 foot curtain
behind you just don't,
it looks good. Um, did they have
screens up so people could see? Yeah,
yeah, they had all of that.
So it was, uh, it was,
it was fucking awesome and a wire to wire.
I had the best time Derosa and
Versie opened up for me to,
Rosa had this fucking old lady
sweater that he had on and it was,
it was bugging me when I was backstage
and then he was just up there and nobody
heckled them for it.
So I just went on stage the first day
that there was just shit on what he was
wearing. So it was very like, you know,
comedy club kind of vibe
and the people would just,
they would just in it from, uh, from
the second I got on there and I, I,
uh, yeah, I just woke up the next day.
There was no let down. There was nothing.
I was like, that was fucking awesome.
I did every joke I wanted to do.
I can't believe I got to do that.
It was,
it was totally a one of the
most satisfying things I
ever did and I, you know,
and then, you know, the next
time I did stand up, you know,
it was from like fucking 20
people down at the comedy store,
but there wasn't like
that old no wood over the dumb shit. I was
just like, oh this is never that. Right.
Cause I know, I know what's what
it fucking write some more shit.
That's the thing about comedy
as opposed to I think music too,
is that we always have to be, you always
have to perform. You've got to keep,
keep banging on it. You always
have to keep coming up new stuff
like you, Chris Rock, Louis, you know,
it's a handful of guys that
never stopped doing the clubs.
I even think those guys that once they
get there following where they just,
you know, work out this shit
in front of their own crowd.
I think that even then that makes it
hurts you a little bit because if you go
down to like the comedy store,
you know, as much as somebody,
if they're a fan of comedy,
might know who you are,
there's going to be a bunch who don't
and there's can be people and it's all,
you know, and the, and the energy is going
to be different. They don't feel like,
oh, I paid to see Joe Rogan.
It's like, oh cool, he's here.
And then after they get over the
five minutes, then it's like, ah,
it's a different,
you know,
it's more difficult as opposed to if
you're just doing your show and you're a
headliner tonight.
Yeah. I did a Melbourne a of weeks
ago and Melbourne's fucking great.
That's awesome. And uh, I did the
comics lounge on Friday night. My,
my theater shows were on Saturday night,
but you know,
they have that comedy club in
town. And uh, we called up,
let them know we're coming in. And
they gave us a spot, me and uh,
Hinchcliffe and it was fucking great
because nobody had any idea it was coming
there.
They weren't necessarily fans of mine and
I got just just fresh packed crowd and
I had legitimate response to your
material. Yeah. That's awesome.
I also feel like there's something about
knowing that the people aren't there to
see you. It puts you in a different
state of mind. Like you, you're,
you're more like, you tighten
everything up. You know, you, you,
you Polish it a little bit.
You make sure that your delivery's a
little sharper because you want to make
sure you let them know,
you know,
like that feeling that you would
get when you first started,
when when you'd open up you'd have to
open up strong because these people like,
who is this fucking,
you know,
like you had to open up strong
and then once you got, um,
you get a get a couple laughs, then they
get a little confidence in your head.
This guy's pretty funny and then
you could kind of carry it on.
So I kind of felt like that I kind
of felt like coming out of the gate,
like I had to have some good shit right
away, you know? I think that's important.
I think that's important
to do those random things.
You just show up at these places
and random soft if you don't. Yeah,
definitely get soft. So I know a lot of
guys, they don't, they don't go anywhere.
They just work out new material in
the middle of their theater sets.
Oh yeah. I mean, I don't know
how they do. I'm on a roll,
I'll fucking throw something out there
like anybody. But like I, you know,
the great thing coming up in the Boston
scene was you got to see at a very high
level what killing is.
And I just, you know,
it has just a lot of guys I've run into,
like wherever they came up,
well I don't know what the headliners
were doing there, but Boston was like,
you know, death. Yeah. It
was like, it sounded like a,
like a fucking train was
coming through the, yeah,
there were Nazi would stock it on a row.
Gavis Sweeney and those guys,
when they would get on a fucking roll
to this day, people don't
know. They don't know.
It's hard to go and you watch the
youtube clips and you go, I don't see it.
You had to be there in like 1989.
You had to be there when the thunder was
happening and those guys were just on
the top of their game that people
get tired of me talking about on this
pod. Duty was fucked up. Those
almost like a height requirement to,
they were all like six, two, six,
three, all of those guys, Lenny,
all those guys are like
at least six foot tall.
They were just a big fucking guys.
Men. They were like, they would
punch you. They would do coke.
Yeah. Yeah. Those stories of, uh,
Lenny punched somebody out one time
cause he stole his joke. I get offstage.
He broke his fucking nose and then
went up and closed out the show.
Yeah. Lenny was an animal. He
was one of the first guys I,
the first time guy worked for, were
open for our, we're open for, um,
Warren Mcdonald. Who was, um,
what was the car we used to fucking do
the open mic night? Bill Macdonald? No,
who's his name? [inaudible]
Michael. Michael McDonald.
He had the same name as the s and guy
with the ponytail. No, it wasn't him.
George George MacDonald.
Yes.
George McDonald used to host the open
mic night and his brother Warren took me
on the road with him one night.
That was the first time I ever got paid.
The second time I ever got paid it
was opening for Lenny. How's that?
Jay's in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
She ever worked for normal, the phone.
Would you ever do any of those gates
feels that way out? Yeah. It's north.
Northwest. Yeah. Kind of. Yeah. Not
quite like Amhurst way, but like, uh,
it was fucking Boone. Dot. But it
was a great gig. It was a great gig.
I fucking loved gag. That gig was so
far and we're doing lean mass. Lee,
Massachusetts, I think for Jeff
[inaudible], Jeff Apotheker,
you just call up his bespoke.
They called up answering machines.
Answering machine would just go
like you've reached Jeff Apotheker
know that you've reached a master
of ceremonies, Jeff apothecary,
nothing like that. And you like you like,
you know, hey, my name is Bill Murray.
I got 10 clean minutes. I can do 50
you know, trying to get you your spot.
So he booked me in Lee,
Massachusetts.
I remember it was exit to off the mass
pike and I went out there and it was the
biggest fucking hell Gig I ever did.
It was this restaurant area and the
next to it was a function where bachelor
party was going on and there was no
door between their Roman and where I was
doing comedy.
So I was standing on stage and these
guys started gathering from the Bachelor
party and just seeing this
fucking redheaded jerk off
the baby face bombing in
front of three people eating chicken pot
pie. And I was looking over, I was like,
I didn't get what was going on because
that was so dumb. I was just like,
hey guys, you want to come into
the shows? Plenty of seats.
I don't know why I got to stand over
there. Right. And I fucking looked away.
And then I just heard,
boom.
I turned around and saw me throw this
fucking dinner roll like 90 miles an hour
at me and just miss me. And I looked
and they were all gone. And, uh,
then I was on the mic, you
know, I snapped, you know,
as you always do when you're like that,
and I forget what the fuck I was saying,
a bunch of shit about them.
And then they started gathering at the
door and I was finishing my set and I was
like, these guys are gonna
beat the fuck out of me.
And I'm looking at the owner now.
The owner told me before I went on stage,
he goes, he goes, yeah. Um,
or the bartender says, he
goes, yeah, this is the owner,
you know, he also does stand up comedy.
And I was like, really? And he goes,
he can guy goes, yeah. He goes, I got
like two and a half hours, their material.
I go, yeah, two and a half hours.
He goes, yeah, and I have to,
tonight I'll have about three.
So I thought he was fucking with me.
So as I'm standing on stage,
after they throw the fucking dinner
roll and shit and they're gathered over
there,
whatever,
I'm trying to go back into my act and
I look out in the crowd and I finally
noticed it in the owner is sitting there
writing down what I'm saying on stage.
And so long story short,
I ended up leaving get off stage
and I was just failing them.
Like to the side of me as I
was getting paid by this guy,
they all I had to do was look at them
and they were going to beat the fuck out
of me was one of those things
where I had to literally just,
I so wanted to just tell
him to go fuck themselves.
But I mean I would have probably lost the
one of them. I'm not the best fighter,
but I,
I was fucking enraged and I just remember
getting into my fucking 83 Ford ranger
driving out of there, yelling at them
as they went on the like, fuck yeah,
you fucking got all high pitched and
just driving home screaming at the my
windshield as I was driving home.
What the fuck out of a fucking owner
has a fucking batch party and you're
writing down my material,
ted, a total meltdown,
driving home and I had to be back up,
back at work the next day at
like seven in the morning.
But what got me through it was I came
home that night and I either called Dane
or Patrice rest his soul and I told
the story and they were just laughing,
which just may, you know, just brings you
back down. And then the guy, you know,
I had this gig and this happened and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. But like,
that's probably the closest I ever came
to getting into at least wine to get
into like forgetting that I didn't know
how to fight. You know what I mean? Like,
you know what I mean? I mean, I could
do some bullshit, but I mean I'm,
there's no way I'm taking on
fucking five fucking guys.
But I just remembered them standing there.
I remember,
I still remember the guy that threw the
rule and I still remember the smile on
his face.
He was just like almost lustfully
wanting me to fucking say something so he
could just fucking beat
the shit out of me.
And that would have been one of those
Boston beat downs where you somebody
fucking bite your ear off. But there
was always that story. Do a kid,
I went to fucking high school,
bit of Guy's ear off, oof.
He was biting is here and the guy pulled
his head away. God took that away.
I met another guy that,
another comic I knew had his fucking
tip of his nose broke bit off.
Oh fuck.
He got into a fight at some frat and he
fucking hit this guy right in the nose.
And the guys knows fucking explode in
his frat brothers grabbed them and they
wrestled to the ground.
And this dude,
he fucking did it to God got on his
chest and he goes payback's a bitch.
And as they held him down, he fucking
bit the end of the guy's fucking knows,
oh my God. And that kid was a rich
kid. So when they sued him and shit,
like they got like just enough money
to reattach the fucking the guy's nose.
Fuck yeah. That's why. That's why I,
those stories were always
fresh in my fucking head. It's
why I stopped. Uh, I mean,
I think like the last fight I had was
at somebody fucking Flint street hockey
yourself that,
so it was probably like junior high.
But after that everybody hit a growth
spurt and that's when like blood and
missing teeth started coming into fights
and I was just like, you know what?
I think I'm going to stick with being
funny. I can, I don't, I don't have,
I didn't have that. Uh,
despite my anger, I didn't,
I didn't want that to happen to me and I
didn't want to do it to somebody that I
really didn't have.
You saw enough of it does that,
that's Dale awful taste of violence
that just sticks with you for like weeks
after it happens.
It just shies away from ever being
involved in anything like that again,
I avoided all that shit when I was
a kid. Yeah, it did. Definitely.
It changes you if you, uh, look,
if somebody is picking on
you and you knock them out,
I think that's fucking great.
I think you'd feel good about yourself.
But there's something about like,
uh, you know, you had just said,
I have friends that just,
their idea of a weekend was going out,
getting into fights dog, and you want to
go dog in this weekend dog. And I said,
that's what they used to call it.
They do this shit with everybody at a
chain in the 80s so all of a sudden when
shit was getting, you know, getting tense,
they'd all be taken the fucking chains
off and putting them in their pockets.
So they're big Z cabaret cheese.
It was fucking insane.
And then they'd be like those 2020 on
20 on 20 fights and some chick would
always try to run in and it's always
get fucking blasted in the face and then
everybody would fucking right. It
was brutal. It was fucking, I'm not,
not saying this is all my friends, this
was just, this was just the environment.
And I,
and I never noticed how fucked up it was
until about seven years after leaving
Boston and really spending long periods
of time away from there that I finally
came back and went into a bar and just
felt the vibe that that somebody's going
to get suckered vibe.
It's just like you just could fit.
And it was weird. You could just
feeling, it was just like, wow,
like I live in New York and New York
has like this fucking crazy thing about
riding subways and shit and the warriors
and you think all of that type of stuff.
But I don't feel that vibe in New
York. Like the thing of, well,
I think the great thing about
New York is that everybody,
the writing of the subway
actually keeps it safer.
I think the fact that everybody's mixed
in together, he had kind of, you know,
the fact that you're on foot, there's
no getaway car, there's none of that.
She kind of had to, you know,
be more civil. You had to
be a great word. Exactly.
It had to be more civil where that shit
where you can just fucking go fucking
nuts. Throw a bottle at somebody
then jumping your eyebrows
z and fish tail down the
street. Yeah, I see. Yeah,
I've heard the first time I took
Ari to Boston, I took him to uh,
to Faneuil hall when they had
the comedy connection up there,
which is about the most pedestrian place
you could have taken him to and a still
filled with psychos. Oh yeah.
All the bars down there.
Phil with Psychos and like as we were
leaving, were walking to the hotel.
We're seeing fucking street
fights left and right.
They were waiting in line at Mcdonald's.
They just decided to get out of there.
They're like, this is too dangerous. We
gotta get Outta here. And then he goes,
you grew up here. I'm like, this is the
spot. This is, this is what it's like.
They fight here, they fight here. It's
Philly. Philly's got a creepy vibe too.
Late night getting a steak and cheese.
You start feeling like somebody going to
catch one and it ain't going to be me.
I'm getting the fuck I'm going
to get this to go. What is it?
Is it the cold weather's a fucking people
that the ancestors of the people that
came over on boats, it's like they're
all stuck. I don't know. There's a,
because to me, New York,
Philly, Boston, they're all,
there's a through line of Sameness
to those kinds of people. And uh,
but I, I think the thing that struck
me about New York was, you know,
they always started, Dave used to try
to equate it to the sports teams that,
you know,
New York would win championships in
Boston other than the Celtics didn't.
But now that even though you know that
we fucking won like a zillion in each,
like it still hasn't gone away.
It is a, there's a, uh, and I,
I what you were saying,
how you have to act more civil there,
there just is that thing in New York where
it's just everybody is like stuck in,
in tight quarters.
So there's a,
there's a level of a common courtesy that
you have to sort of abide by or you're
not going to survive. You can't
walk around being, you know,
like those fucking guys late at night
when you're going to get it, that,
that slice, you know, to absorb
the alcohol so you can drive home,
which was so fucking nuts back then
like that. You weren't going to survive.
You're not going to survive
doing that there. You're
just not going to. So people,
I feel like they behave more civilly,
but um,
sportspeople tried to make it about
the Yankees and red sox and how uh,
it was so funny to me. Like
they would say like, they,
like Boston has an inferiority
complex. It's like, dude,
they don't even know New York exists.
You don't understand like the same way
New Yorkers are all about New York.
The Boston is all about Boston. They
know New York in New York knows Boston,
but they don't know shit about each
other unless you've been there and live
there, you're not thinking about it.
You thinking about your life, you chick,
your world
going look, you know? Yeah. I wish
we would world series like to, yeah,
you don't even think about it
until the playoff series happens.
So I, I think that that
whole thing was just like,
I'm a romantic version of it,
but I really just think of socially.
When you have a city like uh, you
know, I mean, look at La Shit there.
Those have a fucking, every was in
cars. You don't talk to anybody.
People are fucking shooting each other
on the freeways. There's that thing.
When you're in your car,
you just feel like,
yeah, outside of your car, it's a movie.
It's not really happening and then
all of a sudden your car won't start,
and I was like, oh, this
is really happening. Also,
I think the separation of
the classes in New York is,
is different because everybody gets
together on the subway. Rich people,
poor people, they're all together
walking down the street together in La,
there's none of that.
It's a very few interactions between
people from Beverly Hills and people from
Compton or people from east La. There's
none. Unless there's like a benefit.
I'm
shit.
You know what I mean?
There's some political thing and
somebody down there that's 100% true.
This is a problem with his culture here.
There's a great fucking documentary,
which of course I don't
remember the name of it. Uh,
what's his face does the, um, forest
Whitaker does the voiceover for it.
I believe it's forced would occur and
it's just about the history of, uh,
the crips and the bloods.
But what's cool about us is it starts
off and it outlines the neighborhoods.
You know, you always hear Compton,
you hear Watsi here, all these,
but you don't really know where it
is. You know, it's south of whatever.
But they would,
when they would say it,
they'd show a map and then they
would outline the neighborhood.
But they just showed how,
like with like racism,
how they got where they got all African
Americans to live and just all the stuff
that bill.
But it was a really interesting thing as
far as like neighborhoods in la because
La, when you come out here, I still
have to being out here for eight years,
there's no center to the city.
It's just like,
it's just this sprawling fucking
thing that makes no sense. You know,
like the original center of
La was supposed to be long
beach, which makes sense.
You'd want to have it on the water.
Really? Like most major cities. Yeah,
like that's where it was
supposed to be like that.
Whatever that peer is out there that's
like the second or third largest one in
the world.
I think like just the amount of product
that goes in and out during the course
of the day,
so like the major downtown area
was going to be there,
but it was just like la very subtly is
one of the most gangsta towns that there
is out there where it just everything out.
He was just like the water.
Everything is just some fucking CD
goddamn story and there's always like a
fucking decomposed body in every
fucking story. No matter what happens,
they don't give a shit. They just
pave over it. There's no plaques.
This nothing like our Robert
Kennedy got whacked here. Yeah.
You would think like what
they did with Dealey Plaza,
which I actually think they
went overboard. They kept
the entire fucking plaza,
the exact same you walk, they feel like
in, in, in the Zapruder film. Weird.
But like they do the ambassador hotel.
That's where he got whacked. Right, right.
That they took it down.
Yeah. We used to film a film,
fearful to say they used to film shit in
there and then I took that out and now
it's like condos or a school or something.
Something.
I think somewhere there's a little
plaque like, oh, by the way, by the way,
Robert Kennedy got killed here. We walked
through the kitchen where he got shot.
We were hanging around there
when we were filming there.
We're just trying to figure out where
he got shot. We're like a thing.
It was like right here. Yeah. They didn't
have it roped off. There was no memorial.
Nobody gave a shit. Nope. Yeah. That,
that hotel was creepy. There was, it was,
it wasn't being used for like a long time.
It was just, uh, just for filming stuff.
There's a lot of those things like that.
You know,
the original La Times building was
a terrorist act. It was blown up.
I forget why I was reading
this thing about it,
but like there's no information that
I can find on the Internet where the
original one is. There's no plaque
downtown. It's just it happened.
I it's all over. Clean it up.
Barium, let's just fucking move on.
Well I remember from a member of Sopranos
episode where they were talking about
how many actual shipping
containers they actually inspect.
Like what a small percentage of
shipping containers and get inspected.
I thought about that more and
fear factor in Long Beach too.
Cause we used to film there all the time
and we used to be there and we just see
these gigantic ships coming and he's
cargo ships fill with these containers.
I knew what the fuck was in each one of
those things and they were all right.
They're just coming in big giant,
giant.
Everything from bootleg
shit, drugs, blood diamonds,
people to work in fucking rub
and tug prostitutes. Yeah.
Yeah. All on these little weird little
boxes. Ellie's is a strange place.
Strange when you watch those old
movies about La, but it's also great.
I love it out here. It's amazing. It's
a great city, but I also love New York,
but I, I kind of learned that because the
first time I lived out air I hated it.
But I just learned that I was not going
to hate where I was going to live.
Like I was going to give it a fair
shot. You know what I mean? And uh,
it's, you know, the driving is
obviously the worst part of it.
Both the traffic and just how
fucking awful the drivers out here.
They just so fucking then they're maniacs
on the highway and then when they get
off, it's like they took a plot
cookie, like making a right hand turn,
how fucking long it takes.
Or if somebody's car's just
a little in their lane,
how they have to stop.
They can't just fucking drive around.
God forbid you fucking tires go into,
there's nobody coming. Just go. They
won't go. This is fucking unreal.
The terrible with the left lane.
That's a bad one.
Like people get in the left lane, they
never moved from a straight up terrible.
They just terrible.
It's unreal.
And then they get on the fucking highway
and they will drive past you a hundred
miles an hour, pass you on the
right and you're trying to get off.
That's why he's supposed to pass on the
left cause people trying to get off.
You got to go like, like, do you want of
times people will flip me off. It's like,
dude, I'm trying to get off this fucking
thing. You passing me on the right.
There's like no co I think because
people who like commute on the highway,
it's such a motherfucker every day that
if, if they see any bit of daylight,
they just pin it and try to go as far
as they can before they're going to come
to a dead stop again, just to deal with
their frustration. I Dunno. Yeah. These,
these, these are just all theories. Joe,
I think you could live in in New York
again or do you like living out here?
I could live in an outside of the city.
Once you get a house and you don't have
to worry about where I'm going to park.
I don't think people
never lived in a city.
Understand how fucking great
it is to just drive home,
pull into your driveway. Yeah. Right.
And just shut the fucking car off and go.
And now I am a, uh, I, no,
I don't think I would
live outside of the city.
I love New York and I'm like
Westchester or something.
Yeah, whatever. Some long island someplace
up there. I don't know. Long Island.
That's a whole, yeah, and there's
just a lot of meat heads out there.
I just, it's like you're either
fucking, yeah. You're either like,
you're either like a free mason or
you like the dumbest person ever.
That's my experience with long island
and that's doing like the comedy clubs or
like,
it's either like you're,
you got the money to live in the
Hamptons and like, you know, Tom Hanks,
is that your brunch every other
week or like Howard stern or, yeah.
You got these fucking, yeah. You either
got that kind of money or you're just,
I don't know some, you know, I
did a lot of hell gigs out there,
so I probably shouldn't judge it that way.
I did a lot of hell gigs long.
It's long island was brutal.
Jersey hell gigs in Long Island hell gigs.
I think we're worse than the ones that
I did in New England because at least in
New England I was part of
the same drinking water.
So it was the same meathead that we run
into when you went to fucking some gig
in western mass or up in fucking God
knows where in New Hampshire or something.
Main Gate, all those, those
what all those am towns,
Malden, Medford, all of those fucking uh,
Somerville. Somerville now was
like Nice. Yeah, gentrified.
It used to be called Slummerville
when, when we used to do, yeah,
there's like hipsters and cupcake shops
and all that shit. That's it. Seriously.
There are handcrafted coffee,
but like a, yeah, like revere,
revere, all of those fucking
place. Those gigs were brutal.
Revere Road Rudel spot. That's one of
the most brutal spots still, I think.
I don't think that place
has been gentrified.
Malden, Medford, and
there was one other one.
I lived in Medford. They all, you
know, all on the same does it again.
I did gigs and Lynn
Lynn was a raw land too.
I think Connecticut's the worst though
cause Connecticut's depressing to me.
Could it be like Massachusetts was okay
cause that's why I was living. It was no,
it felt normal to me. Like even if it was
a hell Gig, I was like yeah, whatever.
It just sucks.
But there's something depressing about
Connecticut where like Connecticut always
feels like there's no hope.
Like he doesn't feel like a real estate.
It feels like a highway
between Boston and New York.
And then these people just live it on the
highway and then it would come to gigs.
Like to this day, like I did, um,
one of the casinos a few years back,
we did a, you know, a weekend
at the casino and I was like,
I don't ever want to fucking do this
again. This is horrible. One of those,
one of those Indian casinos, I was
like, this place is fucking depressing.
These people are like legitimate
do next time you stay in New York
and then you go to the west side,
you just chop her over
two it chopper over to Connecticut.
Yeah. You Chop chopper everywhere.
Need to be just a straight line.
Like if you went to New York,
would you rent a chopper and fly?
Uh, no. No I wouldn't.
I wouldn't because I'm not familiar with
the airspace. Uh, familiar with like the,
the rate, the amount of work
that I would have to do.
And then also you can get lost up there
really easily. You know what I mean?
And plus you're also like, I mean, dude,
this three international airports, this,
so that's all bravo airspace,
psycho fucking what are you doing here?
Right. The stuff. So when you like when
you transition like Bravo airspace over,
uh, by lax like this, like specific,
like rules of like hardcore,
like you have to say your whole tail
number and the guy has to repeat your
entire tail number. And if he
doesn't, you got to repeat,
you've got to say your hotel number. Just
making sure, you know, number three, two,
three Sierra hotel, you know,
clear to transition, you
know, 500 feet, supple, veto,
whatever. Right? But you know, you
go by regular fucking airports.
It's not that, but the level
of traffic that, that, I mean,
you're talking about you're in the
vicinity of something who had killed 300
people plus people on the fucking
ground. So it's like, yeah,
well I mean I look at it, if I did it
then fuck me. You know what I mean?
Cause I'm an idiot. I'm an
idiot who did it. So it's, it's,
so if I was to rent something there,
and the other thing too is you have no
idea what's going on with that helicopter
either where I fly out of,
I fly the same place where I,
they taught me and those guys
a great school and you know,
the 90% of the flying of those helicopters
is basically done with an instructor
in there. So they're looking to make
sure they don't overspeed the main, uh,
the main road. Then that Yank
and the guts out of it basically.
Because what happens is
every like 2100 hours,
those things are entirely taken apart.
And then rebuilt Greens.
Why they're so safe. Yeah. Do.
Then I just sit like you fucking
fly over people's assistance.
Some shitbox 200 hours
of flying. Wow. So yeah,
and the overhaul like is a,
is a zillion fucking dollars,
which is why if you ever look at a
helicopter like why is this thing only 30
grand? It's cause it's, it's
due for an overhaul. So,
and how much is an overhaul cost?
Like hundreds of thousands.
It all like a hundred. Yeah. It's like you
almost got to buy the thing again. Wow.
And so you have to do that every
2100 miles, 2100 hours, 2100 hours.
2100 hours of flight is a thing.
So if something has 1500 hours on it,
but somebody has been flying it like a
jerk off fucking Yank and the guts out of
the fucking thing is,
then what happens is,
is that 20 to 100 hours where something
could go wrong now becomes 2000 hours or
$1,800 because the thing
about metal fatigue,
like a weld failing or something like
that is you can't see that until it
basically happens.
So if somebody is,
is flying it like an asshole and
they're not maintaining it, you know,
like if you give somebody a fucking
car and they change the oil,
keep it lubed up and all that
and they're not red lining it,
that car's going to last 10 years.
You give it to some fucking jerk off
and they just started up and step on it.
It's a shitbox within fucking
a couple of years so that you,
it's for me anyways,
like just the hours that are on it is
just the first thing I need to know.
Like I'd have to know the school, I'd
have to know who's been flying the flag.
There's no fucking way I would,
I, I wouldn't, I just went.
So do you own your own helicopter or you
rent one? You rent one. Aye. Aye. I rent.
I can't justify doing that. What? So I
can just fly over dodger stadium. Oh,
that was cool. And put it back down. You
know, I uh, you, you fly to gigs, right?
Like didn't you fly to San Diego
for a Gig? Yeah, I flew down.
I flew down with an instructor because
I was the first time I was doing it,
I wasn't familiar and he was handling a
lot of the radio and the calls and that
type of shit. But uh, but I flew the
thing and it was a affluent are 44,
which is a four passenger
is fucking awesome.
You go down there and does he come
with you to the Gig? Oh yeah. Yeah,
it was perfect kid.
Him and his brother came and then a
Kevin Shay wrote in the back and uh,
they had a great fucking time and uh,
it would've been cool if we could
have landed right at the venue,
but what it was was it was in like this
canyon area and there was a bunch of
high wires.
And by the time we got out it was going
to be a nighttime and it didn't want to
fly out of that. So that was the
only sort of buzz kill. But like,
it like flying at night, I got video,
dude. It's fucking unreal. It's really,
it's really, uh, it's a beautiful
thing, dude. Flying out over the ocean.
And just seeing the shit that's out there
that's left compared to what the fuck
we did to it.
But like just the amount of times I've
flown out over there and I just see like
look down like what the fuck is that?
And then you look up a couple hundred
yards of somebody sitting on a surf board
waiting to catch a wave.
You want to be like, dude,
there's something that could swallow
you whole like what'd you see?
I don't know what it was.
I saw a shark or something.
I don't know what I mean you're, it's
weird like when you're up high, like,
you know,
1500 feet of water when whales come up,
like when they're just right at surface
cause they're there body and obviously
all went, when the sun hits it, they
look like almost like glow sticks.
It's really fucking weird.
Like almost like a, I dunno,
what the fuck is it a caterpillar and
it glows one of those fucking glow and
things. That's what it looks
like. But when you download,
there's been a couple of times,
AH, and I've had buddies too.
I know a guy who was doing, uh, you know,
he was flying to thing out for a shoot
and then he's really yanking the guts out
of it, you know, just on that one flight.
But he said he fucking
was coming back around.
They were filming like a boat race
and he fucking came around like that.
You know, he was on his side.
He looked down, he went, whoa.
It was a big fucking great white
shark. Um, near the surface. I mean,
they weren't like real low to the
ground. I mean they were like, you know,
500 feet up,
but you can't miss,
you can't miss a 30 foot 25 foot
fucking a great white or some,
I know I've now pick,
I've ever seen a great white,
but I've seen like you can't pull in.
Maybe it's cause we're up in the air.
It seems like it's closer to the coast,
but you can't believe what the
fuck is due. That's like live,
like no one would walk into the jungle.
You know what I mean? Cause I'd be like,
dude, this is like tigers and lions and
cobras. Sydney, I'm not doing this shit,
but the ocean is the water version of a
jungle and you're just walking into this
shit and your head, well, you fucking
eyes are where you can see everything.
Would you ever walk into a jungle?
Like you know,
I get when somebody finishes
their basement, you know,
you can like push ahead through those
tiles, but have one of those on your head.
You can't see where you're going
and just walk into the jungle.
You would never do that to the ocean is,
is absolutely fucking terrifying to me.
And uh, I, I will never,
never, ever go in it.
So one time I did a flight,
I did a flight to Catalina island
and we're literally, we got like,
when you need to do that, man, you're
flying over water. It's a single engine,
so you got to have flares.
You gotta fucking life jacket on and shit.
And that was the only thing I was
worried about. I was just like, dude,
I'm not even, I'm not even
worried about dying right now.
I'm worried about crash landing into
this shit living and then waiting to
fucking die.
It doesn't happen often, but when
it happens, I never forget it.
There was a guy just
a couple of years ago,
I think maybe just last
year in Santa Barbara Cerf.
I got killed by a great white and my
favorite story was a guy in San Diego
training for a triathlon.
It was him and a few other people.
They were all in a row and they were
all swimming in this fucking whopper.
I said it had to be like 18 plus feet
came along bit the guy in half in front of
everybody and just just, you know, severed
them in half. Killed him right there.
I just bled out. Everyone's
screaming. It's the best.
Swam away the best way. Yeah, just
bite me and half get it over with
a shark coming at me.
I would fucking swim towards my head.
Shove it right in there.
I'm going to have you take a bite
on my leg and see if I'm editing
edible it.
See if you could get a tourniquet on
it before you can hobble the shore. No,
fuck all that. Fuck all of that.
Yeah. It's a, it's a weird way to go.
It is a crazy thing because if
sharks have monkeys, dude, that's it.
Too cheap. That fucking ripped
at woman's face or do they,
you know when they fight each other,
do they take fucking fingers, pull it
off and they fucking Yank the guy
that the fucking ball small bag off.
Okay.
That's the first thing they go for. Fuck
that. They know what makes you a person.
They know your fingers. They go for your
fingers, they tear your fingers off.
They bite them off. They bite your
balls off. Yeah. Yeah. They're ruthless.
They think too.
That's the problem is they're thinking,
do my dog thinks forget
about those things.
The Dad is like, you don't like when
there's just that big guy in a bar.
It was a fucking psycho and
you just sitting there going,
I wish there was somebody big enough to
fucking handle this so I can feel better.
Like that's that times a thousand.
If a chimp just goes, you know,
one of the guys bring
it back to f as a fan.
One of the guys that I work with got
attacked by a monkey one time on when he
was a kid. And, um, and to this day
he had the funniest thing. He goes,
I hate when I go on shoots and there's
monkeys. He goes, I fucking hate it.
He goes, cause what's going
to happen is the, you know,
you're going to get two or three
takes. Everybody knows. He goes,
you do two or three takes.
And then after that the monkeys just
going to do whatever the fuck it wants to
do. And then the handler's going to try
to get it back under the hood or whatever
the fuck it's doing. And uh, yeah, he, he,
I,
it just,
I've never heard any good things about
monkeys when we were in Costa Rica,
we were staying at this nice
resort and they had monkeys.
There were all other monkeys.
Howler monkeys are the worst.
And there was the other ones is Pale faced
monkeys. They weren't the howler ones.
Halloran ones don't come close to you.
But the other ones, he's a little way,
but they won't shut the fuck up.
I was Costa Rica and fortunately
we didn't have those,
but we wanted to rough it. And my
wife was just like, yeah, listen,
I just want to go on in the middle would
be fucking slept under a mosquito net
dude wear in the jungle to,
we will put it this way.
We did a zip line tour through the
northern part of, we did. Yeah,
we were right there.
So we're staying under this
fucking mosquito net and
we have like United States
of America bug spray in like the rain
forest and they're just laughing at the
shit.
It's like,
I'm shooting a pellet gun and the guy's
got a 44 dude. It was like, it was like,
I might as well put a one on two.
I had welts all up and down and
they'll bite and the shit out of us.
And I remember like the
second day, um, this,
these fucking army ants just took
over our, our fucking little,
I don't even know what you'd call it.
There was like these ex
patriots had a fucking,
literally this giant tree
forth that they lived in.
And then they had these little bungalows
so that you had to walk up a ladder to
get into and these fucking things just
took over the place and the guy's like,
came on and I go, yeah, I
did. I came, I was like, oh,
there's like a fucking thousand ants.
And they're like,
they were all in a single file and
he just came washed. He goes, yeah,
those are the army ants. He goes, yeah,
he just can't do anything about it. Uh,
was standing there looking
at him and I got like,
these flip flops on and he goes, you
can't do anything about, I'm just,
you just got to let them pass through,
take a couple of hours. And he goes out,
watch out though. They bite and write as
he said that one of them fucking bit me.
And I was just like,
dude, you gotta be fucked.
Yeah.
So, uh, so they had a monkey
and a spider monkey and pet.
Yup. Not really a pat. I mean,
not pet by its choice, but
he hung out. They had it. No,
they had it as a pet by their choice.
The monkey was was a prisoner. Oh,
so,
so he's in,
so I went over there and it's done
now it's sitting on top of like,
it looks like a birdhouse silicon asshole.
I walk over to this fucking thing like
giving it food and everything and it
fucking jumps on me in two seconds.
It jumped on me inverted,
had its tail wrapped around my neck,
reached into my pockets,
took my bungalow keys and then ran up
the fucking tree with the keys to my
bungalow so I couldn't fucking
get into it and it all,
it all went down in like fucking like
0.3 seconds and things just went wow.
Fucking that was standing there
feeling subhuman. I was like,
I just got out smarter by this thing.
Like this is one for their side and
the monkey was up there looking at me.
I know it's fucking laughing at me
going like, oh you dumb mother fuckers.
Keep it right in your right front pocket.
I get it every time.
So then I was sitting there going like,
all right, all right motherfucker. Right.
You want to have a battle of wits.
Here we go. So I get some food,
right? So I come down and I know
I'm judging, it's fucking leash.
How far can jump.
So it Kinda get all the way back down
on its little fucking bird house,
which was probably about three feet long.
So I'm sitting there walking with the
food and it knows I want the key and it's
actually holding the fucking key away
from its body and seeing if it can have
its cake and eat it like a fucking
human being. Ooh. So yeah. Wow.
So I get the food and
what I did was I set it,
I took a big chunk of whatever the fuck
it was, so we would need two hands.
So it's set down my keys.
So it's set down the keys on the
other side of the fucking thing.
And then it was walking,
it was slowly walking towards it
and right as it got to the food,
this is why I'm a sadistic
castle, raise it, got to the food,
I fucking slapped the food off the
house so it would be out of its reach.
And then I grabbed the fucking keys and
ran and this thing fucking leapt at me.
I swear to God,
I swear to God I could feel its breath
and I fucking made it away to the other
side of it. And it was fucking pissed
at me and I was standing there,
this is middle of Costa Rica going, yeah,
fuck you motherfucker. Fuck you. Right.
So there is the funniest part,
right?
So I go to my bungalow and I'm fucking
still kind of pissed at that fucking
thing and I go and unlock the door and
I'm sitting there for like 20 minutes
reading a book or whatever.
And then I just got on.
I just started thinking about the monkey
and I fucking looked out the window and
it was sitting there all by itself
looking all sad and everything.
And then I felt bad.
So then I went and I got food and
I didn't have my keys this time.
And I actually kind of made
friends with the thing after that.
But I felt when I saw it all lonely
and she, I was like, you know what?
This thing's a prisoner. It doesn't want
to fucking be here. And I'm being dick.
I gotta give it to food. So I gave
it back to it. Yeah, I felt bad.
That's a happy ending. I felt
bad. I don't get it in me. Aww.
That's cute. In the moment I do you know
what else is cute? EPSIS her family. Yes.
Let's say let's end it on that. Okay.
Cause that's a fucking fantastic story.
And a F is for family December 18th.
Yup. Bill bird.com. Is that your website?
Yes it is. And Hilbert on
Twitter, six episodes and uh,
thanks to everybody involved with
the show, Netflix, uh, Mike Price,
everybody over at wild west, Vince Vaughn,
Peter Billingsley, Mike liked niece,
Victoria von,
all those guys,
everybody that helped me out and
we'll definitely be tweeting it.
W The week it comes out,
let everybody know when it comes out.
I'm thinking people, hopefully I
hope they're going to like, oh,
it's Kinda hilarious. Previews. Hilarious.
I know. It's going to be fucking awesome.
Cool. All right brother. Thank you
very much man. It's always a pleasure.
Let me know what you think of
the pot and it smells great.
I can't wait to dig in. I play.
I'm going to give you some elk too.
Don't leave without it. All right
folks, we'll see soon later.